AHEAD AND BEGIN THE HEARING HERE
THIS AFTERNOON I APOLOGIZE OR
START A LITTLE BIT LATE.
I'LL TAKE CREDIT OR BLAME FOR
THAT.
I JUST WANNA NOW SO WE WILL HAVE --
TWO WITNESSES PER SIDE WITH A
TIME LIMIT OF THREE MINUTES EACH.
AND WE'LL ASK ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES STATE ONLY THEIR NAME
AND BECAUSE ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON ON THE MEASURES GO
FORWARD.
WE HAVE OF BILLS PROPOSED FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY --
FIRST OF AND I'LL READ THOSE OFF
NOW -- ITEM NUMBER -- ONE AC ARE
TWENTY EIGHT BY MISTER GIPSON.
I REMEMBER TO ACR ONE OH ONE BY
MR LACKEY.
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY
SIX BY MISS ATKINS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ONE SIXTY
FIVE BY MISS ATKINS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT BY MISTER PANTS SO WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK FOR MOTIONS ON THAT -- ON
THOSE PARTICULAR BILLS -- SO WE
WILL NOW BEGIN -- HE AND FILE
ORDER SO THAT WOULD MEAN THE
FIRST BILL UP AS A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU WITH A C. R..
ONE OH FIVE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF ACR ONE OH FIVE
I ALSO WANNA JUST TAKE A MOMENT
AND THANK THE CHAIR.
OF FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
ISSUE IN GENERAL ON YOUR CO
SPONSORSHIP OF THIS ACR.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT KNOWS
FULL WELL OF HOW OUR COUNTRY HAS
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THE CRISIS
AROUND THE PRICE OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COSTS. SIX FIGURE PRICE
TAGS FOR MEDICATIONS THAT TREAT
COMPLEX CHRONIC DISEASES LIKE
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS CANCER AND HEPATITIS
C..
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY BECOME A
REGULAR OCCURRENCE AND WHILE
THEY REPRESENT IMPORTANT
BREAKTHROUGHS FOR PATIENTS THESE
PRICES HAVE BEEN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON PATIENTS
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
OUR PRIVATE SECTOR AND
GOVERNMENT.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR
OUR NEW GOVERNOR TOOK BOLD
ACTION TO TACKLE DRUG PRICES IN
HIS FIRST EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
LAYING OUT PLANS TO REIN IN.
DRUG COSTS THROUGH A STATEWIDE
PURCHASING SYSTEM.
BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER DID NOT INCLUDE
THE SUGGESTION OF WORKING WITH
MAJOR PLAYERS FROM OTHER STATES.
THIS YEAR THE STATES OF
WASHINGTON AND OREGON IN THEIR
LEGISLATURE'S THEY INTRODUCED
BILLS PURGING -- THEIR
LEADERSHIP TO PARTNER WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE
DRUG PRICES ACROSS THE WEST
COAST.
THIS IS A RESOLUTION TO MOVE FOR
OUR CONVERSATION AND AND SORT US
INTO THAT.
ARE IT WOULD CONFIRM OUR
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
LOWER THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
ARE AND ENCOURAGE OUR GOVERNOR
TO ENGAGE WITH THE STATES OF
WASHINGTON OREGON WHO WISH TO
PARTNER WITH OUR STATE -- TO
ADDRESS THIS AGAIN ACROSS THE
WEST COAST.
IF CALIFORNIA TRULY WANTS TO
LEAD THE NATION ON TACKLING THIS
CRISIS WE NEED TO COORDINATE OUR
EFFORTS ACROSS STATE LINES AS
WELL AS WITHIN AROUND STATE. TO
BETTER ALIGN STRATEGIES AND
INCREASED COST SAVINGS AND WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR TO ARE
THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
A SALE I SEE ACR EXCUSE ME.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR REMOTE COST OF LONG
CALIFORNIA LIGHTS RETIRED
AMERICANS AND NO STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS PUTS TOGETHER THE
PURCHASING POWER OF CALIFORNIA
OF THE EXPERTISE OF THE OREGON
AND WASHINGTON THE MAJOR STEP
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE SERVICE OR ANYONE ELSE.
NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN RING BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
RELIED ON COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT -- IN
DECREASING THE PRICE OF DRUGS
AND IN THE WHOLE TIME WE'VE BEEN
ON THE LATE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TOGETHER SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR
THIS THIS AND I'M HAPPY I
BELIEVE I'M A CO AUTHOR ON THIS --
TO HELP YOU MOVE THIS FORWARD --
WIN THIS.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL
BRING THIS UP IT DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CHRISTIAN ASTRID
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER TO
THANKS.
OKAY MISTER BELL
.
THE CENTER BILL YOU HAVE BEFORE
US SB.
TEN I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
TEN THE PIER PROVIDER
CERTIFICATION BILL.
AND THE BILL ESTABLISHES A
CERTIFICATION FOR PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST.
APPEAR PROVIDER IS A PERSON AS A
LIVE EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
DISORDERS SPECIALLY TRAINED TO
SUPPORT OTHERS NOW FORTY EIGHT
STATES IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
ADOPTED THESE PROGRAMS.
AND HAVE CLEAR BASIC STANDARDS
STATEWIDE. FOR PEER TRAINING.
MEDICAID NOW REVERT REIMBURSES
50% OF THE COST APPEARS SERVICES
IN STATES.
THAT HAVE A STATEWIDE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
IT REDUCING THE FINANCIAL BIRD
BURDEN.
ON OUR COUNTY PROVIDERS.
SO CALIFORNIA IS A LITTLE BEHIND.
AND WE ARE PEERS HOWEVER THAT
WORKED AT THE COUNTY LEVEL DOING
AMAZING WORK BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY STATEWIDE CERTIFICATION.
THE BILL WILL MAKE SERVICE
APPEARS OR OR GET THE TRAINING.
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR BEST WORKS
AND WILL HELP DRAW DOWN THE
FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND I HAVE A FEW WITNESSES ULTRA
MY WITNESS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR ABOUT ALL OF THE AC IN
THE STAINED BURKE INSTITUTE --
AND LA COUNTY FOR SPONSORING
THIS SPELL.
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATES AND
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
LEGISLATION FOR YEARS.
MY NAME IS COLLECT YOU BOZO AND
I'M THE PURE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT MANAGER FOR CAL MESA.
AND I'M HONORED AND THRILLED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
PEER CERTIFICATION.
I AM A FORMER JOURNALIST I AM AN
AUTHOR AND I AM ALSO A SUICIDE
ATTEMPT SURVIVOR -- WHEN MY
MENTAL STRUGGLES?
FIRST EMERGE WHEN I WAS A
TEENAGER I WAS TOLD THAT I WOULD
ALWAYS BE SICK BUT I WOULD NEVER
GET BETTER -- AND THE BEST I
COULD HOPE FOR WAS THAT MANAGING
MY MENTAL ILLNESS -- AND MAYBE
GETTING A PART TIME JOB. FOR
MANY YEARS I INTERNALIZE THOSE
BELIEFS AND MY MENTAL HEALTH
REALLY DECLINED BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO WHAT I NEEDED WAS SOMEONE WHO
HAD A SIMILAR EXPERIENCE TO ME --
WITH MENTAL HEALTH TO HOLD OUT
HOPE FOR ME TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH RECOVERY AND TO
BE A MODEL OF STRENGTH.
I NEEDED UP HERE.
ON MY PATH TO HEALING WHICH
NEVER ENDS -- I MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT LEGISLATION
AND THE INCLUSION OF PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE AND COMMUNITY
APPEARS.
MY EXPERIENCE RECEIVING YOUR
SUPPORT CHANGED MY LIFE.
WHILE WORKING AT PEERS -- IT'S
APPEAR RUN ORGANIZATION IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- I MET A COHORT
OF PEOPLE WHO HAD LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND HELPED ME ON LEARN
SOME OF THOSE REALLY NEGATIVE
PROBLEMATIC THINGS I WAS TOLD --
LIKE THAT I WOULD NEVER GET
BETTER OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT THE
OTHER THING THAT THIS WAS
HELPFUL IS THAT THEY HELP TO
NORMALIZE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH.
SO ONE OF MY CLOSEST ALLIES
GINNY DARDEN -- SHE GAVE ME A
PLATFORM TO TELL MY STORY AND
LISTENED IN A NON JUDGEMENTAL
WAY IT WAS THE FIRST TIME I'D
EVER TOLD ANYONE THAT I WAS A
SUICIDE ATTEMPT SURVIVOR OUTSIDE
OF A CLINICAL SETTING.
AND AFTER I TOLD HER MY STORY
SHE SAID WHILE I'M I'M GLAD
YOU'RE STILL HERE AND WHAT DO WE
DO TO KEEP YOU HERE.
SO.
NEVER IN MY LIFE HAD I HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WAS THIS
HONEST AND I REALIZED I WASN'T A
BIRD AND I DIDN'T HAVE.
TO HIDE AND THE MORE I SPOKE
WITH OTHER PEOPLE LIKE ME I
REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW THEY
REALLY HELPED ME FIND MY VOICE.
MY YOUNGER SELF DESERVED APPEAR
ADVOCATE -- AND DESPITE
INCREDIBLE OUT COMES OUT LIKE
PEER SUPPORT THAT WE'VE DONE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- LIKE A PROGRAM
THAT MATCH SOMEONE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO SOMEONE LEAVING
THE HOSPITAL WHICH ACTUALLY
SHOWED THE DATA SHOWED THAT IT
REDUCED.
HOSPITALIZATIONS -- IT WAS
ATTACHED TO A GRAT WHICH MEANT
THAT ONCE THE PROGRAM WAS OVER
IT WAS OVER WE NEVER HAD MEDI
CAL BILLING SO ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE NOT SUSTAINABLE --
WE NEED TO LEGITIMIZE THE WORK
THAT IS ALREADY BEING DONE BY
PEERS CURRENTLY AND ALSO CREATE
STANDARDIZATION AS
SUSTAINABILITY FOR THIS RECOVERY
BASED WORK.
CALIFORNIA IS RICH IN THE
DIVERSITY OF CULTURE RACE
ETHNICITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER EXPRESSION. FOR THESE
REASONS I HOPE THAT YOU -- VOTE
I ON YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAITING COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL.
THANK YOU SENATOR B<c.cyan> FOR YOUR</c>
TIRELESS AND PASSIONATE SUPPORT
APPEARS SEND YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
THANK YOU ALSO TO CO AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WALDRON CARILLO
AND MAYES.
I'M KERIS MYRICK AND I'M CHIEF
APPEAR SERVICES OFFER LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
PREVIOUSLY I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS --
FOR THE CENTER FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AT SAM SUNG.
AS WELL AS ARE BOTH ON THE NAMI
CALIFORNIA AND THEN ON THE
NATIONAL BOARD SERVING TWO YEARS
AS THEIR PRESIDENT -- OF THE
NATIONAL BOARD I PUBLISHED
NUMEROUS PEER REVIEWED ARTICLES
ABOUT PEER SUPPORT AND BOOK
CHAPTERS ABOUT PEER SUPPORT IN
THE STATE OF THE FIELD.
I COULD GO ON AND ON FOR DAYS
ABOUT YOUR SUPPORT BUT I WANT.
I'LL JUST DO MY THREE MINUTE.
BUT WHAT YOU MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT
ME IS THAT WHEN I WAS GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS OF SCHIZOPHRENIA I WAS
TOLD ALL THE THINGS I COULD NOT.
WOULD NOT SHOULD NOT EVER DO AND
THESE THINGS I HAVE SHARED ABOUT
MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE OR WELL
BEYOND THE IMAGINATION OF WHAT
ANYBODY THOUGHT I COULD ACHIEVE
EXCEPT WELL MEME MAYBE MY
PARENTS.
THOUGHT I COULD DO IT AS WELL AS
VERY INNOVATIVE TREATMENT TEAM
THINKS THE ONLY DIEM H. -- AND
ALSO -- TO MY PEERS THE FIRST
HERE I MEANT WAS ACTUALLY -- AND
AT THE AGE OF FORTY AND IT WAS
SOMEONE WHO LOOKED JUST LIKE ME
A LITTLE BIT OLDER.
BASICALLY -- LIKE ME AND THAT'S
WHEN I FINALLY GOT IT THAT
RECOVERY IS INDEED POSSIBLE.
I'M AND SHE HELPED ME TO HELP
MYSELF THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
ACHIEVE -- ARE THE VERY ONES
THAT REQUIRE PEOPLE IN DISTRESS
TO BE MET WHERE THEY ARE TO BE
HEARD AND TO HAVE SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN THERE AND DONE THAT TO
PARTNER WITH THEM.
WHILE IT SAM SO WE PROVIDE A TA
TO STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA TO
ADVANCE THE PIER WORKFORCE.
INFO PRIESTESS DESCRIBE --
OUTCOMES THAT PEERS CAN ACHIEVE
AND THE WORK THAT THEY DO --
HELPING PEOPLE GAIN SKILLS AND
CONFIDENCE AND PARTICIPATING IN
TREATMENT AND AND SUPPORT IN
USING SHARED DECISION MAKING.
INCREASING SELF ADVOCACY FOR
PARENTS REDUCING STIGMA FOR
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
AND REDUCING SHAME AND BLAME AND
ALSO REDUCING HOSPITALIZATION
WHILE INCREASING.
THE COMMUNITY.
SO WE CAN ACHIEVE THESE OUTCOMES
ACROSS THE STATE WITHOUT
CONSISTENCY AND TRAINING THAT'S
BASED ON A COMMON SET OF CORE
COMPETENCIES PRACTICE GUIDELINES
AND ETHICS.
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER PROFESSION
AND A RIGHT YEAH THOSE OTHER
FORTY EIGHT STATES THAT ALREADY
HAVE IT.
SO THIS HOPE THIS BILL WILL HELP
US HELP THIS STATE TO HELP THOSE
IN NEED WE WANT TO FLIP THE
SCRIPT ON THE EVERYDAY HEADLINES
THAT WE SEE AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
LACK OF TIMELY ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE SERVICES AND
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF SUICIDE
PEER SERVICES SAVES LIVES WE
NEED TO TAKE OUR PLACE ALONGSIDE
OTHERS IN THIS STATE PROVIDING
SERVICES AND BEING REIMBURSED BY
MEDICAID. TO DO EXACTLY THAT
HELP SAVE LIVES AND I'LL END BY
SAYING ON JULY FIFTH IT IS MY
MOTHER'S BIRTHDAY HOWEVER MY
MOTHER'S LONG LONGER WITH US SHE
NEVER GOT TO SEE ME GET BETTER.
SHE NEVER GOT TO SEE ME LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY SHE NEVER SAW ME
GO BACK TO WORK AND SO THIS YEAR
I'VE DEDICATED ALL OF EVERYTHING
THAT I DO TO HER BECAUSE SHE
ALSO HELPED OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
AS WELL.
AS A FAMILY SUPPORTER SO I ALSO
DEDICATE THIS TO ALL OF OUR
PEERS WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN
SAVED AND LOST -- BUT MANY
PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES TO
EARLY AND TO THE FAMILIES THAT
MORE IN THEM.
SO I REALLY ASK -- TWO YEAR FOR
IT I VOTE TO ADVANCE OUR PEER
WORKFORCE SUCH THAT WE CAN
INCREASE OUR ABILITIES AND
CALIFORNIA'S MOVEMENT TO
TRANSFORM THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SYSTEM TO SAVE LIVES SELECT FLIP
THAT SCRIPT ON THOSE HEADLINES
AND NOW WITH THE TIME WE LOOK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER SINCE
SUPPORT -- JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
ONTO SOME HALF OF ITALIAN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISS CHEN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
COUNTY HUMBOLDT CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND CALIFORNIA COUNTY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAXINE AND TELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ME OF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN WOULD MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN CLARK WITH SENATOR FAMILY
OF AGENCIES IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND I'LL FRAUD WITH CREW
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN JOSE
MAYOR SAM LICCARDO AND ALSO
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA HAVE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
SIMEON GAP CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
J. MED KERR CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
ASKING WHAT IS CALIFORNIA
WAITING.
FOR ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THERESA COMSTOCK WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IN
SUPPORT.
HEIDI STRONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
REHABILITATION AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
AS WELL I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND SELF STRONG
SUPPORT AS WELL.
SIMON VIEW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATINUM VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NON THE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AMANDA LEVY CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT -- MICHAEL READY GET
SKEWS ME MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD SUPERVISOR
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KELLY BOX HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS.
AND THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORSHERE IN SUPPORT I'M
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHO'S ACOSTA BOX
BECAUSE WATER THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
TOBY EWING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT ACCOUNT OF
THE ABILITY COMMISSION ALSO A CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF PEACH
THE PRIVATE ESSENTIAL ACCESS
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS IN SUPPORT.
MAURICE RICHARDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE WITH
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. TWO MEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE MAYOR CALLS EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THURMOND DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
D'ANGELO MAC ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SALAS IN MEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE RUN
ORGANIZATIONS AND A VERY VERY
LONG TIME ADVOCATE.
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT FINALLY.
HI AM VERY EARLY STONE WITH
CAMPBELL SPIEL CC AM ASKING FOR
YOUR FULL SUPPORT.
MAKAYLA JOHNSON PETE P. O. THIEF
THE MEMBER AND ALSO WITH LIVE
IT'S BURIED AMID TO HELP I'M
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEAM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
VIRGINIA HALL AND WITHOUT CAMPRO
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH.
CARE I AM A PEER SPECIALISTS AND
STAFF TO THE PUBLIC POLICY IN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF SB TEN THANK YOU.
ABOUT THE KNOWN I'M GORDON REID
I'M WITH BEHAVIOR HEALTHCARE
SERVICE POLITICAL SUMA
CHAMPIONSHIP PERSON.
HI I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TO QUITE A
LARGE A BOTTLE FROM YOU CC AND
THE MARIST BRIGHT -- I SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE LEFT GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAMELA JORDAN
I AM A CERTIFIED SPECIALIST.
I AM FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I AM
FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
DOCTOR ROBIN JOE WELCOME MUCH OF
CIVIL RIGHTS HUMAN RIGHTS AND I
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MEYER CORONA AND I SUPPORTERS SB
TEN IN BEHALF OF PULL CONSUMER
CHAMPIONS AND ALSO -- LIKE ANY
KANNADASAN IN OAKLAND MENTAL
HEALTH.
YES MY NAME IS KENNETH DAVIS I'M
A MEMBER OF A THE P. OCC AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF BLACK MEN SPEAK.
IN -- FOR SO FOR FOR SUPPORT
PRESS BE TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY ANYONE
ELSE.
SEE NO ONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT WILL STOP THERE FOR A SECOND
WE HAVE A QUORUM BECAUSE IT
WE'RE GOING TO GET THAT.
TAKEN CARE BAD CHECKS A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I HEAR MAYES
SQUARE AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE CARRILLO.
FLORA LIMóN.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WE GOT IT ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SAYING.
SENATOR BILL YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND -- DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO THANK MY
WITNESSES -- FROM COMING HERE --
I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZE --
HERS FOR NATIONAL LEADERSHIP FOR
IN THE CHAIR OF NAM A NATIONALLY.
AND HER SERVICE TO UNITED STATES
AND FOR MENTAL ILLNESS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND YOU FOR COMING IN -- GIVING
YOUR PERSONAL STORIES SO.
I THINK THOSE PERSONAL STORIES
WAY ALLOWED OUR MINDS AND
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THIS --
THIS IS GOING TO BE A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNI URGENT ABLE THANK
YOU.
AS I SAY THANK YOU TO THANK YOU
CENTER BILL THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOUR WITNESSES FOR COMING TODAY.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT --
WITH THAT -- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER RAMOS A SECOND BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY.
MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SOME LAST MINUTE
SECTOR TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE CARILLO.
I FLORA FLORA AYE LEVEL.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WE HAVE EIGHT VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF COMMITTEE
BUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN
.
GIVE US ONE MEMBER WHO THEY'LL
THE BILL TODAY.
WE HAD THE WEATHER CONFLAGRATION.
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO BUTTE COUNTY.
DESTROY THE WHOLE TOWN TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE DISPLACED.
IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE.
AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND WHO LIVED
ON THE RICH WHICH IS A LARGE
RIDGE THAT CARRIES UP FROM CHICO.
TO PARADISE AND BEYOND.
ALONG WITH.
THE MANY PROPERTIES AND HOMES.
ALSO WE LOST THE HOSPITAL.
IT WAS THOUGHT THAT WE LOST
EVERYTHING.
BUT LATER EXAMINATION SHOWED
THAT THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN
COULD BE.
REHABILITATED.
AND IT WAS IT'S BEEN DETERMINED
THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT.
AND THIS BILL HELPS FACILITATE.
THAT EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT RUN BY
THAT VANISHED.
IT COULD BE FUNCTIONING AS I
SAID WITHIN A FEW MONTHS BUT WE
DO NEED TO HAVE THE BILL.
THE BILL IS LIMITED IN SCOPE.
PROVIDES ONLY.
FOR THE E. R..
AT FOR THE RIVER.
IT HAS GOT TO THE INSTITUTIONS
ASKED TO COMPLY WITH NURSE
PATIENT STAFFING RATIOS.
PROVIDE CLINICAL AND LABORATORY.
TECH MEDIC LOGICAL SERVICES ON
SITE.
WHICH THEY CAN DO.
AND HERE TO ALL EMERGENCY ROOM
REGULATIONS.
IN THE STATE.
IT CAN APPLY FOR A TWO YEAR
SPECIAL PERMIT TO OPERATE
OPERATE THESE ER SINCE SERVICES.
AND REAPPLY TWICE.
OVER A MAXIMUM OF SIX YEARS.
SO.
AND ANY RENEWAL REQUIRE A
COMMUNITY NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
NOW STAND ALONE E. OURS HAVE NOT.
BEEN COUNTENANCED IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS THERE
HAVE BEEN AND I WOULD ASK.
ONE IN THIS CASE.
BECAUSE IT IS AN URGENT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
DARN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE UP
THERE THAT.
WOULD REQUIRE.
THE EMERGENCY CARE.
AND IT'S A LONG RUN. TO CHICO
[inaudible]
OR ELSEWHERE [inaudible]
THE ADVENTIST SYSTEM.
A VERY GOOD FUNCTIONING
[inaudible]
ONE TRUSTED ENORMOUSLY.
IN OUR AREA.
YOU HAD SUGGESTED SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE.
AND I CERTAINLY WILL ACCEPT AS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS. TO CLARIFY.
THE TRANSFER AGREEMENTS THAT
THIS E. R. WILL HOLD WITH ANY
OTHER HOSPITAL NECESSARY.
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THEY LEAVE THE EMERGENCY
THEY WOULD HAVE SOMEWHERE ELSE
TO GO.
AND TO CLARIFY THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE LABORATORY.
AND THE SERVICES [inaudible]
ON SITE.
AND THERE WAS SOME REPORTING
REQUESTED.
I GUESS BY STAFF.
I'M SATISFIED WITH THAT IF THE
SPONSORS.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE THAT COUNT.
THE END OF THE CERTIFICATIONS.
THAT SAID THIS IS A VERY URGENT
SITUATION FOR US UP THERE ON THE
RICH.
THE PLACE IS COMING BACK THE
FRANKLY IT'LL TAKE. TWENTY YEARS.
THEY EVER GET EVEN CLOSE TO
WHERE I WAS ONCE UPON A TIME.
BUT THAT DOES NOT DIMINISH THE
HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
OF THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THAT RICH.
A DESK AND I WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
SUPPORT THIS THAT SHORT OF A
HALF OF ADVENTIST HEALTH WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR -- AND THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR THE WORK
ON THE BILL AND AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT -- I HAVE BEEN
OFFERED THE US PEDESTAL
REPORTING REQUIRES YOU THINK
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ISOLATE ON THIS
PROGRAM -- IN OUR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SO WE WE ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE THAT WE AS THE SENATOR
SAID WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
CAMPFIRE HAS CREATED A VERY
UNIQUE SITUATION -- AND IT'S
BEEN DEVASTATING TO THIS
COMMUNITY I'M I'M GOING TO
INTRODUCE FOR CROSSING WITH
ADVENTIST HEALTH YOU CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD MEAN FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT -- IN SHERMAN WOOD.
I AM RICK ROSSIN THE PRESIDENT
OF EVIDENCE HEALTH AND RIGHT OUT
WHICH INCLUDES SEVEN THIS HEALTH
OPERATIONS AND BUTTE COUNTY.
PARTICULARLY FOR THE RIVER
HOSPITAL IN PARADISE.
HAVE BEEN A SELF INCLUDES
SEVENTEEN HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA THE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOSPITAL BASED
RURAL HEALTH CLINICS.
WE HAVE A DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT TO RURAL HEALTH CARE
ANSWER SOME OF OUR STATES MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL IN
PARADISE CALIFORNIA IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT COMMITMENT.
BEFORE LAST FALL'S CAMPFIRE IT
WAS A ONE HUNDRED BED THRIVING
ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL THE HAVE
BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR NEARLY SEVENTY
YEARS.
THE HOSPITAL SERVED A RURAL
COMMUNITY WITH MORE THAN 80% OF
OUR PATIENTS COVERED BY MEDICARE
AL OR MEDICARE.
MANY WITH SUBSTANTIAL CHALLENGES
AND TRAVELING DISTANCES FOR THE
CARE THAT THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES NEED.
WE EMPLOYED MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
LIKE MOST OF THE COMMUNITY OF
PARADISE OUR HOSPITAL SUSTAINED
SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGES DURING THE
CAMP FIRE.
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF THE ACUTE
CARE FACILITY RECEIVE SUCH
DAMAGE HAS TO BE AN OPERABLE THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WAS NEWER
CONSTRUCTION AND HAVE SUSTAINED
ONLY LIMITED DAMAGE.
OUR COMMUNITY WHILE DEVASTATED
CONTINUES TO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
PRIOR TO THE FIRE THE FEATHER
RIVER EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SAW
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY PATIENTS
PER DAY.
MANY OF THE AREA HOSPITALS HAVE
SEEN LARGE INCREASES IN THEIR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
SINCE THE CAMP FIRE WHICH IS
IMPACTED ACCESS TO CARE ACROSS
THE REGION.
PEOPLE FROM NEARBY TOWNS ARE NOW
TRAVELING AS LONG AS AN HOUR TO
REACH AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AND FACING LONG WAITS ONCE THEY
ARRIVE.
IN ADDITION LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
ESTIMATING THAT A MINIMUM OF TWO
THOUSAND UTILITY AND
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE COMING
TO WORK.
IN PARADISE EACH DAY WORKING IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THEIR
WORK THESE WORKERS ARE MORE AT
RISK FOR INJURY REQUIRING
EMERGENCY CARE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
PARADISE MAKE ALIYAH AND OTHER
NEARBY COMMUNITIES WOULD BENEFIT
FROM HAVING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES RESTORED IN PARADISE.
WE APPRECIATE THE UNIQUENESS OF
OUR REQUEST.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE AN EXCEPTIONALLY
UNIQUE SITUATION.
WE DO NOT YET KNOW WHICH OF OUR
NEIGHBORS WILL BE COMING BACK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN AND WHERE
BUILDING OR REBUILDING WILL
OCCUR.
AND WE WON'T FOR AWHILE.
HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THAT RIGHT
NOW OUR COMMUNITY IS IN
DESPERATE NEED. FOR THE CARE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WILL
PROVIDE NEEDED CARE THE OTHER
TYPES OF CLINIC FACILITIES KING
CANNOT INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN EMERGENCY CARE AND
DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES.
PROVIDED BY HIGHLY SKILLED AND
VALUED EMERGENCY SERVICES --
PROFESSIONAL STAFF.
WHEN OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
PAID PATIENTS NEED A HIGHLY
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE WHAT
STABILIZE WE ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THE HELIPAD THE CAN HANDLE ALL
EMERGENT TRANSPORTS?
HELICOPTER SERVICES CAN GET A
PATIENT TO A NUMBER OF HOSPITALS
INCLUDING RIGHT OUT HOSPITAL
WHICH IS PART OF OUR SYSTEM.
IN TWENTY MINUTES INTO AND LOW
MEDICAL CENTER IN LESS THAN.
TEN DURING THE TRANSPORT
PATIENTS WILL BE UNDER THE
CONSTANT CARE OF TRAINED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX WHILE
WILL ALLOW EVAN THIS HELP THE
RESTORE ROLE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
TO OUR COMMUNITY WHILE
CONTINUING TO ASSESS WHAT THE
COMMUNITIES MEDICAL NEEDS ARE AS
OUR COUNTY REBUILDS.
WE REMAIN AS COMMITTED AS EVER
TO PARADISE SAM BUTTE COUNTY AS
WE ASSESS WHO COMES BACK AND
WHAT SERVICES THEY NEED.
AS WE HAVE FOR MANY YEARS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO RESPOND AND
SERVE.
IN SHORT TERM HOWEVER HAVE BEEN
A SELF IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX WHICH
IS AIMED AT BRINGING NEEDED
EMERGENCY SERVICES BACK TO THE
DEVASTATED.
COMMUNITY OF PARADISE AND WE
JURADO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CENTER FOR BRING THIS
FOR AN M..
I'VE BEEN IN YOUR FOOTSTEPS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF ORDER
FOR THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS FOR
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR OUR RAVAGED
A AREAS AND I'M.
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE BEING THIS FOR
TO BE HONORED IF I COULD BE A CO
AUTHOR.
INDEED SO AND WHERE YOU'RE NOT
IN MY FOOTSTEPS ASSEMBLY LOAN
WE'RE FOOT STEP SIDE BY SIDE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU SAN ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP BRING THEM PARTICULAR
SOCIAL BACK.
TO THE LOCATION SO JUST TWO
QUICK QUESTIONS HOW BIG IS THAT
YOUR ONLY PATIENTS.
CAN THEY HAVE ON TEN TWELVE BED
THE FACILITY OR FACILITY YOU
KNOW [inaudible]
WE WE WE WILL NEED TO DETERMINE
THAT -- WHEN WE SET THE SIZE BUT
I I BELIEVE THEY'RE ABOUT TWENTY
BEDS AND EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SO
IT IS A SUBSTANTIAL SIZE IT
COULD HANDLE OVER A HUNDRED
PATIENTS A DAY?
WHEN -- BEFORE WE EXPECT LESS
THAN THAT -- BUT IT'S IT'S OF
SUFFICIENT SIZE IT'S ACTUALLY
CONSTRUCTION THAT WAS BUILT.
APPROXIMATELY TEN YEARS AGO SO
IT IS FAIRLY NEW AS REAL AS IT
RELATES THE RUSSELL BUILDING
OKAY THANK YOU I LOOK FOR
SUPPORTING THE THINKING.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE WOULD THINK THANK YOU
CENTER FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- OBVIOUSLY -- I THINK
WE ALL KNOW -- THE HORRIBLE
DEVASTATION THAT HAS COME DOWN
ON YOUR DISTRICT.
AND THAT OF MR GALLAGHER AND MR
DOLLY BEFORE NOW SENATOR
OBVIOUSLY AND YOU TOO WELL THIS
YEAR. TO THE WEST TO THE WEST TO
BE THERE SO -- SO -- THIS DOES
DO ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I WOULD ASK AN IDOL
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M SECRETARY
WE HAVE A A MOTION BY MISTER
MAYES -- A SECOND BY MISTAKE
YEAR CURRY THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ALONE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROSS ROSS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
GIVE TEN VOTES THAT'S MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A GODSEND TO PARADISE
AND THE RICH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT SOME WOMEN AND SEVEN WOMEN --
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT SB FIVE
NINETY I'D FIRST LIKE TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION IS A MAJOR%
PART OF CONTEMPORARY AMERICAN
LIFE HOWEVER.
ALCOHOL DEPENDENCE AND ABUSE
IMPOSES AN ENORMOUS BURDEN ON
INDIVIDUALS FAMILY.
AND OUR STATE.
ALCOHOL ABUSE HAVE SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
CARDIO VASCULAR DISEASE
HYPERTENSION DIABETES LIVER
DISEASE FETAL ABNORMALITIES AND
EVEN CANCER.
AND I'D SAY IT'S ABOUT 5% OF ALL
DEATHS ARE ATTRIBUTED. TO
ALCOHOL MISUSE.
IS ALSO ESTIMATED THAT A
WHOPPING A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION IS SPENT
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ON ALCOHOL RELATED PROBLEMS LIKE.
LOST PRODUCTIVITY DUE TO ALCOHOL
RELATED ILLNESSES.
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES MOTOR
VEHICLE CRASHES CRIME AND OTHER
SOCIAL COSTS.
MORE CLOSE TO HOME IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ABOUT 90% OF
CALIFORNIANS REPORTED EITHER
BINGE DRINKING OR CHRONIC
DRINKING.
SB FIVE NINETY PROVIDES ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO TRY TO
HELP THOSE WHO SUFFER WITH
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY AMENDS
THE LANTERN MEN PETR SHORT ACT
TO INCLUDE THOSE SUFFERING FROM
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM IN THE
EXISTING SCREENING PROCESS.
THIS INCLUSION WITH THEIR FALL
OUT ANY PERSON.
INCLUDING A PARENT OR A SIBLING
OR A SPOUSE TO PETITION.
A COUNTY DESIGNATED ENTITY. TO
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL OR A LOVED
ONE WHO IS SUFFERING WITH
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
A DANGER TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
OR IS GRAVELY DISABLED TO BE
SCREENED AND ASSESSED.
THIS EVALUATION WITH US INITIATE
A FIFTY ONE FIFTY INTENSIVE
TREATMENT OR CONSERVATORSHIP IF
NECESSARY.
SB FIVE NINETY IS A SMALL CHANGE
IN THE ALREADY EXISTING
FRAMEWORK OF THE LAW. TO GIVE
HOPE TO INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WERE SUFFERING FROM
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
SB FIVE NINETY GIVES HOPE TO
SAVE ONE MORE LIFE AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PER SECOND US HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THIRTY
ONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REALLY --
IN OPPOSITION ABOUT THE PROCESS
AS A BE ANALYSIS NOTE THE NOTES
THAT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE JUST APPROVED THE LPS
AUDIT AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
PROCESS PLAY OUT BEFORE WE LOOK
AT LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR BIGELOW.
MR GOT A RAISE TO A REALLY VALID
POINT THE JACK JUST.
CONCLUDED.
HOW DO YOU?
LOOK AT THAT HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THAT APPRECIATE THE THE
QUESTION THAT YOU LOCK REQUET
IS -- BASICALLY LOOKING AT THREE
COUNTY IS TO LOOK AT THE
EXISTING PROGRAM.
THIS IS SIMPLY ADDING ANOTHER
PARAMETER AS WE KNOW ALL CALLS
NOT A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE SO IT
DOESN'T FALL WITHIN THE LAND
COMPETITORS ACT.
THIS IS JUST GOING TO ADD
ALCOHOL.
AND THEN CERTAINLY IF THERE WAS
NOT IT LATER AFTER OUR CALL WAS
INCLUDED BECAUSE HE THE EFFICACY
OF ADDING IT AND WHETHER OR NOT
WE ARE.
HELPING PEOPLE WITH THEIR LIVES
SO THIS WAS A A NARAL ON IT TO
THREE COUNTIES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EXPAND THIS TALL.
FIFTY EIGHT BEING ONE THAT CAME
FROM COUNTY LAND.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH -- FOLKS THEY'RE
THEY'RE RUNNING THOSE PROGRAMS
THE LIMITED DOLLARS IT MAKES.
IT MAKES IT HARD FOR ME TO DATE
IT REALLY.
I WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT YOU BUT
I KNOW HOW LIMITED THOSE DOLLARS
ARE AND THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
ENCROACHMENT ON THAT.
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
IT ISN'T THAT THE FOR THOSE
FOLKS THAT ARE DRINKING DON'T
NEED HELP.
I JUST THINK THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BETTER PLAY
THIS OUT TODAY.
SO I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND THE
DILEMMA FACING HERE HAVING BEEN
A FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR ME AS
WELL.
AS WELL AND YOU KNOW HOW IT OR
HOW IT IS TO DEAL WITH THIS SO
ANYWAY I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THIS IN NO -- ONE I'VE.
ALWAYS FOR SANTIAGO I'M SORRY.
ONE PROJECT FOR NOT BEING HERE
FOR THE ENTIRE PRESENTATION BUT
I LOOK I I THINK IT'S I THINK
SUPPORT YOU TAKE UP THE ISSUE I
CARRIED SOMETHING SIMILAR US
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AND I KNOW THAT EMOTIONS RUN
HIGH -- AND I KNOW THAT THEY'LL
BE ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
COMMENTS AND I'M NOT TABLE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE THE WHAT
YOU NEED TO ASK YOURSELF NOT YOU
BUT GENERAL YOU.
IS WHAT'S THE WORST OF TWO EVILS
AND IN MY CASE WE WERE PURSUING
FOLKS WHO NEEDED MEDICAL
NECESSITY -- ADMINISTER AMOUNT
OF CRITERIAS I STILL BELIEVE
THAT -- IS THAT ALL THE
PROTECTIONS ARE THERE BECAUSE
GOOD BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE TO
GO TO A PARTICULAR PROCESS --
FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL -- AND AND ON
TOP OF THAT THAT AT THE END OF
THE WE'VE GOT TO FIND SOME SORT
OF SOME SORT OF WAY OF GETTING
PEOPLE IN IN THE IN THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT THEY NEED EVEN IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO THEMSELVES OR
UNWILLING TO DO IT ON THEIR OWN --
IT'S A DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
LOOK I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
FACT THAT YOU ENGAGED IN IT YOU
KNOW.
AT SOME POINT I WOULD WANT TO
COMPARE NOTES ON OPEN TO EXCITE
NOT ON TO THIS PROCESS.
A COUPLE TIMES I WOULD AGREE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
I THANK YOU FOR RING THE BELL
FORWARD -- DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I AM I AM SORT OF
SURPRISED ALMOST THAT IT ISN'T
ALREADY INCLUDED QUITE FRANKLY --
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- AS I
SAID IT DOESN'T JOINT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- NO THAT WOULD
INSPIRED THIS BILL IS SAID I HAD
A WONDERFUL AND HER NAME WAS
REVEILLE.
AND I CAME FROM A VERY MODEST
INCOME FAMILY AND HAD.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE WITH HER
WELL I WAS GOING TO PHARMACY
SCHOOL.
AND ONE THING THAT JUST WASN'T
TALK ABOUT IN THE FAMILY WAS THE
FACT THAT SHE HAD A ALCOHOL
PROBLEM.
AND I LEARNED IT WHEN I GOT UP
ONE MORNING AND WENT TO
BREAKFAST AND SAW HER THERMOS
WHEN SHE WASN'T LOOKING AND I
TOOK A SIP OF WHAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE WATER.
IT WAS JUST PURE VODKA AND SHE
WAS A FUNCTIONING ALCOHOLIC IN A
SCHOOL TEACHER [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY ALCOHOLISM AND THE
ABUSE OF AMPHETAMINES WRITTEN BY
HER DOCTOR -- ENDED UP COSTING
HER LIFE AT FIFTY SEVEN YEARS
OLD.
SO IT'S IT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
TOOLS FOR FAMILY MEMBERS THAT DO
RECOGNIZE THAT.
ALCOHOL ABUSE IS A PROBLEM ABOUT
BLESS YOU.
AND IT ALLOWS JUST ONE MORE TOOL
FOR US TO GET AN EVALUATION OF
THOSE THAT WE WE LOVE AND I'M
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
HONOR OF MY AND RICKY AND HOPE
THAT YOU'LL SUPPORT BUT WHEN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WE HAVE A MOTION BY --
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
FLOOR THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ALONE.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
ROSS I RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. TO GET
EIGHT VOTES THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE BUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAFF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SOME WOMEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE DO -- WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
AUTHORS WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
BILLS LEFT WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR -- MOTION BY MISTER --
MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
SANTIAGO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
INCLUDES ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR
TWENTY EIGHT BY MISTER GIPSON I
REMEMBER TO ACR ONE A ONE BY
MISTER LACKEY.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY SIX BY
A SENATOR ATKINS I REMEMBER
SEVEN SP ONE SIXTY FIVE BY
CENTER ATKINS ITEM NUMBER NINE
SP FOUR TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PAN.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER --
MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
SANTIAGO -- FOR THE CONSECUTIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES RIGHT
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE
LIMóN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THE AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE REBELS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
CONSENT.
I LIVE ON AYE.
AND THE CONTENTIOUS CONSENT
COUNTERS PASSED -- ELEVEN ZERO
WILL BE THE REAL LOOKING FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON CENTER MONEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
BEFORE US SB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
IN MEMBERS.
UP BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS WHICH WILL CLARIFY THE
BILL'S LABELING PROVISIONS.
DO NOT APPLY TO UNSEAL BEVERAGES
WERE THE PURCHASER OR SELLER CAN
ADD SUGAR AT THE POINT OF SALE.
SUCH AS AT A COFFEE SHOP.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL.
THREE FORTY SEVEN IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF A BROAD PUBLIC
HEALTH CAMPAIGN THAT SEEKS TO
LIMIT THE HEART HELP HARMFUL
HEALTH IMPACTS.
THAT SUGARY BEVERAGES CONTINUE
TO HAVE ON THE HEALTH IN HAPPY
IS HAPPINESS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
SKYROCKETING RATES OF OBESITY
AND PREVENTABLE TYPE TWO
DIABETES CONTINUE TO WREAK HAVOC
ON THE HEALTH OF FAMILIES IN ALL
OVER DISTRICTS.
IN BURDEN OUR STATE WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS RELATED TO THE
TREATMENT.
OF THESE PREVENTABLE CHRONIC
DISEASES.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN WILL
EMPOWER CONSUMERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THE
BEVERAGES THEY PURCHASE.
BY REQUIRING A SCIENCE BASED
HEALTH WARNING LABEL TO BE
PLACED ON SUGAR SWEETENED DRINKS
THAT ARE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THE
CONTAINS SEVENTY FIVE CALORIES
OR MORE.
OF ADDED SUGAR PER TWELVE FLUID
OUNCES.
MEMBERS HEALTH WARNING LABELS
ARE PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE MEANS
OF INFLUENCING CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
HAVE BEEN USED SUCCESSFULLY ON
TOBACCO AND ALCOHOL PRODUCTS FOR
DECADES.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN WILL
PROMOTE INFORM TO CONSUMER
CHOICE IN A LEAD TO BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REMOVE DRINKS
FROM THE SHELVES IT IS NOT TAX
THEM.
IN AT NO WAY PREVENTS CONSUMERS
FROM BUYING WHAT THEY WANT.
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES THEM WITH
SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE SEVERE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
SUGARY DRINK CONSUMPTION.
IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY
IS ARGUED THAT SODA TAXES AND
PORTION CONTROL LEGISLATION
UNFAIRLY IMPACT THEIR INDUSTRY.
AND CONSUMERS AND INSTEAD
CLAIMED THAT EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC ABOUT HEALTHFUL CHOICES
IS THE BETTER PATH FORWARD.
I AGREE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
IT EDUCATES CONSUMERS.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
ALLOWS A CONSUMER TO LOOK AT A
STORE SHELF AND IDENTIFY WHICH
CAMOUFLAGED PRODUCTS.
CONTAIN ADDED SUGAR.
IN WHICH PRODUCTS ARE MORE
HELPFUL.
CONSUMERS ARE FREE TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS AND ARE AIDED ONLY
BY THE ADDITIONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION.
MEMBERS ONE IN THREE CHILDREN IN
YOUR DISTRICTS.
BORN AFTER THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND IS PREDICTED TO
DEVELOP DIABETES IN THEIR
LIFETIME.
IN THAT NUMBER JUMPS TO ONE INTO
FOR LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN.
ASKS THAT YOU JOIN ME TODAY.
IN THE ENTIRE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMUNITY.
IN TAKING A BOLD STEP.
TOWARD PREVENTING THE STATISTIC
FROM COMING TRUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME THROUGH THE
CHAIR LIKE TO PRESENT.
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
STARTING WITH DOCTOR CO FOR
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DOCTOR FLOWS ON CO FOR
AND I AM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
POLICY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES.
TOGETHER WITH THE CONFERENCE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
THE LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB THREE FORTY SEVEN TO
PLACE WARNING LABELS ON SUGARY
DRINKS.
THE SCIENCE ABOUT THE LINK
BETWEEN SUGARY DRINKS AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES IS INCONTROVERTIBLE SO
OPPOSITION IS CENTER THEIR
PLATFORM AROUND SEVERAL THE
SEVERAL EASILY REPEATABLE
ARGUMENTS WHICH I WILL.
ARGUMENT NUMBER ONE IS THAT
WARNING LABEL SIMPLY DON'T WORK.
AND SIMPLY STATED THIS IS FALSE
ACCORDING TO A STUDY PUBLISHED
IN THE PEDIATRICS IN JOURNAL IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN WARNING
LABELS ARE THREE TIMES MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRIES CLEARING CALORIE
LABELS.
IN HELPING PARENTS CHOOSE A
DRINK WITHOUT ADDED SUGAR.
THESE PARENTS WERE ALSO MORE
AWARE OF THE STARTLING FACT THAT
CONSUMING JUST ONE SUGARY DRINK
PER DAY INCREASE THEIR RISK OF
CAVITIES TO FOLD DIABETES BY 26%
AND OBESITYBY 55%.
AND THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT SODA
WARNING LABELS HELP CONSUMERS
DISTINGUISH GREEN PRODUCTS LIKE
1100% FRUIT JUICE AND FRUIT
FLAVORED DRINKS WITH ADDED SUGAR
WHICH ARE OFTEN OTHERWISE
INDISTINGUISHABLE. FOR THIS
REASON THREE QUARTERS OF
CALIFORNIA VOTER SUPPORT WARNING
LABELS WITH EVEN HIGHER SUPPORT
AMONG BLACK AND LATINO RESIDENTS.
ARGUMENT NUMBER TWO IS THAT
WARNING LABELS KILL JOBS THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE COST OF
PRODUCTS TO RESTRICT THEIR SALES
IN ANYWAY.
BUT NO LEGISLATION WILL STOP
PEOPLE FROM BEING THIRSTY THAT'S
JUST HOW OUR BODIES WORK DATA
FROM BERKELEY SHOW THAT AFTER
THEIR TAX WAS ENACTED NO JOBS
WERE LOST BECAUSE PEOPLE STILL
BUY DRINKS THEY JUST BOUGHT.
LOWER CALORIE DRINKS THE SAME
PATTERN CAN BE EXPECTED HERE.
ARGUMENT NUMBER THREE IS THAT
THE SAN FRANCISCO WARNING LABELS
OVERTURNED THE PANEL DID IT DID.
RULE AGAINST THE SAN FRANCISCO
WARNING LABEL BUT ONLY BECAUSE
THEY FELT THAT THE 20% FIVE
REQUIREMENT WAS LARGER THAN
NECESSARY.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THE RULING AND THE JUDGE'S
OPINION IN THAT IT DOES NOT
SPECIFY A MINIMUM SIZE OF THE
LABEL ONLY MINIMUM FONT SIZE FOR
LEGIBILITY.
AND THAT IT USES THE JUDGES
RECOMMENDED PHRASES OF TYPE TWO
DIABETES AND MAY CONTRIBUTE.
AND THE LAST ARGUMENT NUMBER
FOUR THE FDA SAY SUGARY SAFE.
THE FTC SUGAR SAFE EXCEPT WHEN
CONSUMING EXCESS AMOUNTS AND SB
THREE FORTY SEVEN TARGETS HIGH
CALORIE DRINKS THOSE WITH SUGAR
ADDED SUGAR AND MORE THAN
SEVENTY FIVE CALORIES PER TWELVE
OUNCE.
THE EXCESS AMOUNTS THERE
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RISK OF DISEASE.
OUR OPPOSITION THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIBER CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION HAVE STATED THAT WE
SHOULD WORK TOGETHER GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITY TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS
AND EMPOWER THEM TO MAKE CHOICES
THAT ARE BEST FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN IS THE
POLICY ANSWER TO THIS PLATITUDE
GIVE CONSUMERS THE INFORMATION
SO THEY CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT WHAT TO DRINK.
THIS BILL IS ESSENTIALLY ABOUT
WHOSE VALUES WE LOSE INTEREST WE
VALUEMOST.
CONSUMERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
THIS INFORMATION THEY WANT TO
KNOW THIS INFORMATION AND THE
OPPOSITION DOESN'T HAVE A
FACTUAL OR CONSISTENT ARGUMENT
AGAINST APPLYING THIS
INFORMATION. FOR THESE REASONS I
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARLENE ON THE
LAW I AM A GRADUATING SENIOR
FROM ROLES OF ALL HIGH SCHOOL IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS.
SENATE BILL THREE HUNDREDFORTY
SEVEN IMPACTSME BECAUSE MANY
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY IN THE
OIL HEIGHTS AREA AND IN HIS LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WITHIN.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAVE
BEEN DRINKING TOO MUCH SUGAR
WITHOUT KNOWING IT HOW MUCH
SHOULD WE DRINK DOES HAVE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES IN MY
COMMUNITY EAST LA HAS.
THE HIGHEST RATES OF DIABETES
AND LOS ANGELES -- AMONG
STUDENTS ONE OUT OF THREE HAVE.
PRE DIABETES THERE IS ALSO A
HIGH PREVALENCE OF OBESITY AND
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE BUT DIABETES
OBESITY AND HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
AREN'T.
ONLY BECAUSE BECAUSE OF
STURBRIDGE DRINKS BUT CONSUMING
THESE FREQUENTLY INCREASES THE
RISK OF HAVING THESE RISKS.
MANY FAMILY LIVE WHERE HIGHS
SUFFERED THROUGH A CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AND I BELIEVE IT'S
TIME TO CHANGE THESE OUTCOMES.
OVERALL THOUGH LET THAT'S A NICE
COMMUNITY ALSO FACES THESE
CHALLENGES.
AND BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THEIR
REGULAR.
OF LIKE.
DALY.
DAILY DIET OF CONSUMING THESE
COVERAGES AND NOT HAVING THE
HEALTHY BEVERAGES OPTIONS THE
HIGH NUMBER OF HELLO.
NIGHT COME CONVENIENCE STORES
MAKE DEALS STRENGTH EASY AND
CHEAP TWO AXES AND WITHOUT
LABELS MANY OF US DON'T THINK
THAT.
THESE STRINGS ARE HOME FOR FOR
US -- IN FACT WE ALL TEND TO SAY
THAT.
COKE IS A CURE ALL SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF SOMEONE SAY'S THAT
THEY'RE NOT FEELING WELL WE SAY --
DRINK THE COKE YOUR STOMACH
HURTS DRINK A COKE.
LE. FOR THOSE WHO WHO KNOWN AS
SODA ISN'T GOOD.
WE WANT TO GET THESE DIFFERENT
CHOICES BUT IT'S DIFFICULT WHEN
WE DO NOT KNOW HOW.
TO DIFFERENTIATE NAY BE HEALTHY
DRINKS FROM THE THE SUGARY
DRINKS.
SO I BELIEVE ADDING.
A HEALTH WARNING LABEL ENTRE
WEIRD DRINKS WILL ALWAYS.
THE HELP EVERYONE TO TELL
WHETHER.
THOSE DRINKS HAVE A LOT OF ADDED
SUGAR OR WHETHER THEY DO NOT --
IT WILL ALSO HELP [inaudible]
MANY PEOPLE. TO TO THINK OF OF
THE NIGHT THE ONE TIME PER DAY
HOW IT AFFECTS US.
AND IN FIVE LAKE.
I KNOW THAT FOR WOMEN WE CAN
ONLY DREAM ABOUT LIKE TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY TEASPOONS I
BELIEVE ON A TRIP FOR THE BUT
ONE CANDIDATE IS MORE.
THAN WHAT A WOMAN SHOULD HAVE TO
DRINK WELL I AM HERE BECAUSE
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT.
THESE RISK. TO HAVE.
A LOT OF SIGN.
WELL PEOPLE HAVE THE THE RIGHT
TO KNOW THAT.
SUGARY DRINKS ARE HARMFUL AND
THEY AFFECT OUR HOUSE AND
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO LIVE
FREE OF PREVENTABLE DISEASE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME TO PROMOTE
THE AWARENESS ON ON HEALTHY
BEVERAGES AND TO TO PUT THOSE
LABELS ON SUGARY DRINKS.
FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
CHOICE AND NOT SUFFER FROM THESE
DISEASES THAT THEY MIGHT FACE
LATER ON IN LIFE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT JUST TO NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE ASHLEY
WALKER WITH ANNOUNCEMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY SILVER RESIDENT BOYLE
HEIGHTS ANY STILL IN THE STILL
SOUNDLESS IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BELINDA COMPOST RESIDENT OF
SANTA CLARITA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAT TO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SIMEON GANT CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK AND CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HELPLESS ADVOCATES ADVOCATING
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING CAR ALL AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SORRY I'M AGREE WITH CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DISCUSS THEIR HOME AT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE HAVING OUR SAY COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EVERY GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORTER S.
AS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
RONALD COLMAN ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIRTY ONE
IN OPPOSITION
.
YOUR SHERMAN MEMBERS JOHN
LATTIMER ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND
PEPSICO.
OUR MEMBERS SELL HUNDREDS OF
DIFFERENT BEVERAGES TO CONSUMERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THOSE BEVERAGES ARE FULL
CALORIE WITH ADDED SUGAR SOME
LOW CALORIE WITH ADDED SUGAR
SOME NO CALORIE NO ADDED SUGAR.
THE POINT BEING WE ARE GIVING
CONSUMERS A FULL RANGE OF
BEVERAGE CHOICES.
THE MANUFACTURERS AS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW BUT THE CLERK
INFORMATION EACH CONTAINER TO BE
MORE EVIDENT TO CONSUMERS.
THE KILLER WORK IN A CONTACT.
THE POINT BEING CONSUMERS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DRINKING.
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
ARGUE THAT CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES PRESENTS A
UNIQUE DRIVER TO THE OBESITY AND
DIABETES CRISIS.
SO MUCH SO THAT ONLY THESE SUGAR
SWEETENED PRODUCTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WARNING LABEL.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT POSITION DOES
NOT ALIGNED WITH WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
RESEARCH BY THE CDC SHOWS THAT
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
CONSUMPTION FROM SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES HAS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY. 26% FOR ADULTS
AND 36% FOR YOUTH.
YEAH ADDITIONAL RESEARCH BY CDC
SENT NATIONAL CENTER FOR HEALTH
STATISTICS REPORTS THAT OBESITY
RATES DURING THAT SAME PERIOD OF
TIME REXI RISING.
CLEARLY SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE
CONSUMPTION CAN'T BE BOTH
FALLING AND AT THE SAME TIME BE
THE LEADING DRIVER OF THE
INCREASE IN OBESITY THAT JUST
DOESN'T ADD UP.
SO WHAT ARE CONSUMERS DRINKING
ACTUALLY TODAY TODAY OF ALL
BEVERAGES PURCHASED 50% OF THEM
ARE ACTUALLY CONTAIN ZERO SUGAR
AND THAT NUMBER IS ON THE RISE.
CONSUMERS ARE MAKING THIS CHOICE
FOR THEMSELVES.
THE PROPONENTS ALSO RAISE THIS
IS THE SPECTER OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES BEING THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF QUOTE ADDED
SUGARS IN THE AMERICAN DIET.
THE CHALLENGE OF THE DATA POINT
IS IT CAN SOUND MISLEADING.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
TRACKS CONSUMPTION OF CALORIES
FROM FOOD PRODUCTS IN THE US
DIET AND BREAKS IT DOWN INTO
SEVEN DISTINCT CATEGORIES.
FOODS AND BEVERAGES CONTAINING
ADDED SUGARS IS ONE OF THOSE
DISTINCT CATEGORIES.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY NOT THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF CALORIES IN
OUR DIET IT'S NOT THE LARGEST OF
THOSE CATEGORIES.
IN FACT THESE FOODS AND
BEVERAGES ARE THE FOURTH LARGEST
CATEGORY REPRESENTING
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF THE
CALORIES IN THE AMERICAN DIET.
SO WHILE WE MAY DISAGREE WITH
THE CHARACTERIZATIONS SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES ARE THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF ADDED SUGARS
IN THE AMERICAN DIET.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THAT
NUMBER IF IT'S A CORRECT NUMBER
WHICH WE DISPUTE IS STILL 8% OF
THE TOTAL CALORIES.
IN THE DIET CONSUMED AND THAT
NUMBER AGAIN IS DROPPING.
SO WILL NOT ALL INSIGNIFICANT
THE SOURCE OF ADDED SUGAR AND
CALORIES CANNOT BE THE DRIVER OF
THE MUCH LARGER PROBLEM.
THAT IS OUR FRUSTRATION THIS
MUCH LARGER PROBLEM OF OBESITY
AND DIABETES AND THEREFORE DOES
NOT WARRANT THE ONLY STATE
SANCTIONED WARNING LABEL WITH
THAT PASSED FOR NOTEBOOK.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE MANY MISTRAL COOK I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION A CMC IS OPPOSED TO
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN IT IS ONE
OF THE BILLS THE SESSION -- THAT
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED AS A
MANUFACTURING BREAKER I
LEGISLATION THAT IS EARNED THAT
DISTINCTION HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS A POLICY THAT WILL NOT JUST
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
MANUFACTURERS BUT WILL
IMMEDIATELY INDUCTOR MENTALLY
ALTER CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS.
PRODUCTION AND OPERATIONS IN A
WAY THAT WILL COST US REVENUE
JOBS IN OUR ABILITY TO COPE
EFFECTIVELY COMPETE IN THE
GLOBAL MARKETPLACE SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN DOES ALL THESE
THINGS -- IT'S CALIFORNIA ONLY
WARNING LABEL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON A SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURING JOBS CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER ONE HUNDRED
MANUFACTURERS THAT BOTTLE IN
PACKAGE BEVERAGES MANY ARE SMALL
INDEPENDENT MEDIA.
SMALL AND MEDIUM INDEPENDENT
MANUFACTURERS THAT COMPETE FOR
CONTRACTS A BOTTLE MANY PRODUCTS
FOR MULTIPLE BEVERAGE COMPANIES
ONE FACILITY MAY SERVE MANY
DIFFERENT COMPANIES THEY THRIVE
WHEN THEY CAN OPERATE AS HUBS
FOR MULTI STATE AND
MULTINATIONAL PRODUCTION.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
ONLY WARNING LABEL PULLS THE RUG
OUT FROM UNDER THEM CHANGING THE
ECONOMICS OF ITS OF DRINK
PRODUCTION AND ENCOURAGING THEIR
CLIENTS TO CONSOLIDATE THE
REGIONAL OPERATIONS.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
LIKEWISE SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
ENCOURAGES THOSE POTENTIAL
CLIENTS THAT MAYBE SMALL
EMERGING BEVERAGE COMPANIES TO
BEGIN THE PRODUCTION OPERATIONS
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
A CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LEADS THE
NATION ANY SORT OF START UP
MANUFACTURERS BUT SB THREE FORTY
SEVEN REPRESENTS AN ADDITIONAL
COST PLEASE CASH STRAPPED
COMPANIES PUSHING THEM TOWARDS
GROWING THERE COME THEIR
OPERATIONS.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA IN A STATE
WHERE ONE FACILITY CAN PRODUCE A
LABEL FOR A PRODUCT THAT CAN
ENTER DOZENS OF MARKETS SO TO BE
CLEAR SB THREE FORTY SEVEN WILL
SLOW DOWN THE PRODUCTION THAT'S
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WILL RESULT IN THE LOSS
OF WELL PAYING SOMETIMES SIX
FIGURES MIDDLE CLASS OFTEN UNION
BETH -- ORGANIZE JOBS WITH
BENEFITS.
I KNOW THE TYPE OF JOBS WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE RE WHY YOU MAY
NOT SEE JOB LOSS IN A SINGLE
CITY -- IS BECAUSE THE PRODUCTS
BEING SOLD IN THAT CITY WERE
MADE OUTSIDE OF IT -- APPLYING
THIS SCHEME TO THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PUSHES PRODUCTION
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
THEIR JOBS CREATED.
THEY'LL BE OUTSIDE OF OUR STATE --
ANDTHEIR MANY TAP CALIFORNIA
TOWNS I CAN TELL YOU THE IMPACT
ON COMMUNITIES HEALTH WHEN THESE
TYPE OF JOBS GO AWAY.
SO SB THREE FORTY SEVEN WE'RE
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
BENEFITS ARE QUESTIONABLE AND DO
NOT WAY OUT WAY THESE NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS SB THREE FORTY
SEVEN MAY POTENTIALLY MISLEAD
CONSUMERS INTO THINKING THAT A
DRINK WITH LESS SUGAR.
IS MORE HARMFUL THAN A DRINK
FOOD OR CANDY WITH TWO OR THREE
TIMES AS MUCH SUGAR IT CREATES
MORE CONFUSION IN THE UNIVERSAL
STANDARD THAT CURRENTLY EXIST
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE.
ENERGY TO OPPOSE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR SECURE MEMBERS MET CERTAIN
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL LARGE BUT WITH PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON THE RESTAURANT
OBLIGATIONS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- MEMBERS AARON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERRY MCCUE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN WINGER IBF CALIFORNIA FEELS
INCONVENIENCE ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
VALERIE NERVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JEFF SIEVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CAN MANUFACTURES INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION. THIRTY IS THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MORE TOP ON THE HAVE ONCE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
KATE ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA OUR
MEDIC VENDORS COUNCIL -- YUM
BRANDS SEVEN ELEVEN AND CHECK
THE BOX OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MISS THE CHANCE WITH THE ALSO
MARKS MORE HERE ON BEHALF OF
DUNKIN BRANDS WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
IT WITHOUT WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SONORA BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
DIRECT MY COMMENTS TO MY FELLOW
ROUGHRIDER AMMA PROUD ALUMNI
ROSA HIGH SCHOOL AND I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR COMING UP TO
SACRAMENTO TO THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
BEFORE I LOSE MY VOICE I JUST
WANTED TO SAY YOUR ADVOCACY IS
IMPORTANT AND DESPITE WHAT
HAPPENS WHETHER THIS BILL GETS
OUT OR GETS ON THE FLOOR.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE HERE
AND THEY CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY
THE RISE IN DIABETES HEALTH
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE LATINO POPULATION
EAST LA.
AND ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
MCCARTY.
GET THANK YOU -- MISTER MISTER
CHAIR SO I I I SUPPORT THIS BILL
I SUPPORT A COUPLE YEARS AGO --
MY PROPS DOING VERY WELL UP
THERE -- CENTER MINING AND I
THINK YOU'RE TAKING IT TO THE
NEXT LEVEL BUT BUT IN ALL
SERIOUSLY WHY WE'RE HERE IS
BECAUSE THE CONSUMER HAS NO IDEA.
AND SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY IT'S
IT WILL BE A WORTHLESS MORNING
IN THE CALORIES ARE ON FRONT I
CONCUR THAT THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION.
ON THE FRONT OF THE PACKAGE.
AS OPPOSED THE BACKED IN YEARS
PAST BUT I DON'T THINK THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER MOM K<c.cyan> DAD</c>
FAMILY MEMBER.
KNOWS WHEN THEY BUY A TWENTY
OUNCE.
BOTTLE OF COCA COLA THAT YOU
LOOK AT THAT.
SUGAR AND DIVIDE BY I THINK IT'S
THREE POINT NINE AND REALIZE
THAT THAT.
HAS SIXTEEN TEASPOONS OF SUGAR.
AND IF YOU ARE SOMEBODY WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING THEIR ICE TEA IF
THEY PUT. ONE TEASPOON IN.
THIRTY TWO THREE AFTER SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE TEN DO THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT.
LITTLE TOO MUCH. SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN PROBABLY TOO MUCH.
AND I THINK THAT THE CONSUMER
DOESN'T NOW AND AND I WOULD I
WOULD PREFER NOT JUST.
A WARNING AS FAR AS THE GENERIC
WARNING BUT HAVE ACTUAL
TEASPOONS OF SUGAR BECAUSE THE
GRAMS OF SUGAR.
YOU KNOW MOST PEOPLE DON'T GET
THE LONG DIVISION MATH AND
FIGURING OUT ON THE FLY.
SO -- YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE AND LOOK THERE'S NO PERFECT
SCIENCE IT SHOWS THAT THIS IS
THE REASON FOR THE OBESITY
EPIDEMIC BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE
EMPTY CALORIES THAT PEOPLE ARE
UTILIZING THESE DAYS I MEAN
CHOCOLATE CAKE IS ONE THING
HAMBURGERS.
BUT THOSE AT LEAST HAVE SOME
NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
THESE DRINKS ESPECIALLY THAT
SUGAR SWEET ONES -- HAVE HAVE
ZERO NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
IN THE INDUSTRY THAT THEY ARE
JUST TAKING THE RIGHT STEP
CONSUMERS ARE VOTING WITH THEIR
FEET IN THEIR POCKET BOOK IN.
THE INDUSTRY IS PROBABLY MAKING
JUST AS MUCH OR MORE MONEY OFF
THE OTHER DRINKS THE KNEES AND
SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE ANSWER IS
GOING TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS BY
NOT SELLING AS MANY OF OF THIS
DRINK WE HAVE BEFORE US.
AND YOU KNOW I I I I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE BIG HARM AS OF THIS AND
I I I DON'T QUITE GET HOW?
IT'S A JOB KILLER IT'S
INFORMATION PEOPLE ARE STILL
MANUFACTURE PRODUCE THIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY SELL IT.
WHERE THE FOURTH THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND
I'M GONNA GO AWAY THE SOUL TO
SELL THEIR PRODUCT WITH THIS
LABEL?
OR Nó LABEL -- AND I I JUST --
I KNOW THAT THIS IS A TOUGH
FIGHT.
IS BIG BUSINESS AND BIG INDUSTRY --
BEHIND THIS -- JUST LIKE WE FACE
IN THE TOBACCO FIGHTS IS IS A
BIG BIG DEAL IN OUR SOCIETY SO I
APPLAUD YOU FOR STICKING OUT IT --
I DO HAVE JUST TWO QUESTIONS FOR
THE OPPOSITION AND I'M KIND OF
CONFUSED SO I UNDERSTAND I KNOW
MR A LOT OF YOUR YOU SAID
REPRESENT BOTH THE RETAILERS AND
PEPSICO SO I UNDERSTAND THE
PEPSICO ARGUMENT THAT THE NOT.
NOT LIKE IN THIS BUT FROM THE
RETAILERS AND THE CONVENIENCE
STORES WHAT'S THE THAT THE
STRONG AND VERSION FROM THERE
IT'S A BABY SELLING THE PRODUCT
WITH A LABEL WITHOUT THE LABEL.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME SOME FINDS
IN THERE AS FAR AS AT AND
HARASSED BUT BUT I'M TRYING.
TO FOCUS ON THE NEXUS FOR THEIR
STRONG OPPOSITION SURE.
AND IT'S SO SIGNIFICANT SO MY
RETAIL MEMBERS NEARLY EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM ALSO HAS
THEIR OWN PRIVATE LABELS THEY
ALSO STOCK ACTORS MANUFACTURERS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
NOT NOT ONLY IN THE AREA OF
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES BUT
ALMOST ANYTHING THAT WE OFFER.
YOUR LOCAL GUY AND YOU GO TO
BAILEY'S IN BELLAIRE YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN BRANDS THAT
WE'RE THE MANUFACTURER IN THOSE
INSTANCES -- SAME IS TRUE FOR
SAFE WAY SAME IS TRUE FOR VON SO
WHERE MANUFACTURERS AS WELL AS
OUR READ THAT AS WE ARE
RETAILERS.
THE THING IS WE SELL AGAIN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FOOD AND BEVERAGE
PRODUCTS WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THE
CONSUMERS.
IS ACCURATE -- WE DON'T DISPUTE
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
CONSUME TOO MUCH SUGAR WHAT WE
DISPUTE THE FACT IS THAT THIS
PRODUCT SINGLE THE CONSUMPTION
RATE WHICH IS DROPPING IS THE
ONLY PRODUCT THE NEEDS TO HAVE A
WARNING LABEL.
IT DOES CONVEY FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THIS IS THE COST
PRODUCT AND SO WE DISAGREE
FUNDAMENTALLY WITH THAT BOTH AS
A MANUFACTURER AND AS A RETAILER.
SURE I CAN AND THEN THAT'LL I AM
REALLY HAS TO THINK THE LAST
INTO THIS IS THE ONLY PRODUCT
WHICH HAS. ZERO NUTRITIONAL
VALUE AND AND AND THE OTHERS
KATIE CHEESE BURGER AND SO FORTH
IT DOES HAVE SOME.
NUTRITIONAL VALUE THESE THESE
THAT THESE ARE EMPTY CALORIES.
SURE AGAIN YOU CAN GET IN A
GREAT DEBATE ABOUT THE CALORIC
VALUE OR THE NUTRITIONAL VALUE
WE DON'T.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE SOFT DRINKS
THOSE BEING SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES THAT ARE -- CARBONATES
OFFERINGS ARE ARGUING THEIR
NUTRITIONAL VALUE THIS BILL
HOWEVER APPLIES TO MANY PRODUCTS
INCLUDING THOSE THAT HAVE
NUTRITIONAL VALUE THIS IS NOT
JUST LIMITED TO SODA THIS IS ANY.
BEVERAGE THERE ARE.
PEPSICO MAKES TROPICANA JUICE.
YEAH WE HAVE A PRODUCT CALLED
DROPPED FIFTY WHERE WE TAKE 50%
OF THE NATIONAL RECURRING SUGAR
OUT WHY BECAUSE IT'S A LOT OF
CALORIES IN A 100% FRUIT JUICE.
AND WE REPLACE THAT THAT
NATURALLY OCCURRING SUGAR WITH
SOME SWEETENER THAT BOOK THAT
PRODUCT WOULD CARRY A WARNING
LABEL ON THAT PRODUCT HAS PLENTY
OF NUTRITIONAL VALUE SO AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A UNIFORM APPLICATION
THAT WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT --
SODA POP SURE AND I UNDERSTAND
WITH THE REALLY IS FOR EXAMPLE
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN PRODUCT LINE.
BUT THE THE THE GAS STATIONS I
GUESS THE ASSOCIATION IS THE
FUEL CONVENES ASSOCIATION.
THEY DON'T MAKE THEIR OWN
PRODUCTS DO THEY DEPENDS I AGAIN
I DON'T REPRESENT THEM SO I
CAN'T SPEAK TO A BUT I HAVE BEEN
IN SOME OF THOSE THOSE -- STORES
I BELIEVE PERHAPS EXTRA MILE HAS
THEIR OWN I THINK SEVEN I KNOW
SEVEN LEVIN AS OUR OWN BRAND IT
VARIES ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND IT AND THEN AS FAR AS THE
THE MANUFACTURING IN THE JOB
SINGLE AND AND THESE OTHER
ARGUMENTS.
IN AS A WHOLE I WANTED TO IF IF
THROUGH THE MISTER CHAIR IF WE
CAN ALLOW.
THE AUTHOR -- TO I KNOW HE'S
GOING TO CLOSE IN A LITTLE BIT
CLICK.
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU THROUGH THE CHAIR.
SO I THINK THE MANUFACTURING
CONCERNS ARE EXAGGERATED WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN A DIVERSIFICATION
OF PRODUCTS.
I THINK YOU'LL FIND THAT THE
DATA SHOWS A REDUCTION IN
CONSUMPTION OF SODA PRODUCTS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS WHAT WE
CALL CAMOUFLAGE PRODUCTS SPORT
T..
ENERGY DRINKS NO NUTRITIONAL
VALUE HI LOADED SUGAR CONTENT
BUT TO THE QUESTION ON
MANUFACTURING.
IF YOU LOOK AT PRODUCTS.
THAT WOULD CARRY THIS LABEL.
CAN TO BEVERAGES BOTTLED
BEVERAGES.
IF YOU GO TO THE STORE THIS
WEEKEND YOU'LL SEE SOMEONE
FOURTH OF JULY LABELS ON THEM.
FOOTBALL SEASON YOU'LL SEE NFL
PLAYERS ON THEM.
CHRISTMAS TIME HOLIDAY TIME
YOU'LL SEE HOLIDAY LABELS.
THE INDUSTRY IS ADEPT THEY
CHANGE THEIR LABELS FREQUENTLY.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO PUT THEM
OUT OF BUSINESS.
IN THROUGH THE CHAIR IF IF I
COULD JUST ASK THE DOCTOR TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTION.
THAT WAS ASKED TO THE OPPOSITION.
OUT OUT OUT HOW WELL DO THAT
FREQUENT PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- THE THE QUESTIONING IN
TERMSOF THE CONSUMPTION OF
SUGAR THOSE DATA THAT OUR
NATIONAL DON'T NECESSARILY
REFLECT THE TRENDS ARE HAPPENING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE PUBLISHED A STUDY WITH UCLA
LAST YEAR SHOWING THAT THE
SUGARY DRINK CONSUMPTION AMONG
CHILDREN IS ACTUALLY INCREASING --
AND THAT KIDS AS YOUNG AS TWO OR
INCREASED.
I'M CONSUMING SUGARY DRINKS AND
THE SUGARY DRINKS OUR DRINKS
THAT ARE MASKED AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED -- ONES THAT PARENTS
DON'T RECOGNIZE AS SUGARY DRINKS
ESPECIALLY ENERGY DRINKS IS HIGH
IN THEIR AND YOU'LL REMEMBER
THAT -- THAT WE PASSED
LEGISLATION DETERMINING THAT IN
SCHOOLS -- MANY SUGARY DRINKS
CAN'T BE SOLD EXCEPT ENERGY
DRINKS WERE CARVE OUT AND SO
WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE IN THOSE
DRINKS BECAUSE THEY WERE LEFT
BEHIND AND FORTUNATELY -- THE
OTHER THING THAT THAT REALLY
WASN'T MENTIONED WAS THE FACT
THAT THE ONE WE WILL DOESN'T
JUST FOCUS ON OBESITY THE
MORNING LIVE ALSO FOCUS ON
DIABETES AND CAVITIES I DON'T
THINK THE OPPOSITION WOULD WOULD
LEVY AN ARGUMENT THAT THEIR
PRODUCTS DON'T CONTRIBUTED THOSE
AND THAT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT'S LEADING TO THE TRENDS
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN TERMS OF
DENTAL DENTAL HEALTH -- AS WELL
AS DIABETES IN THE STATE SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIABETES OR WHO
ARE AT RISK FOR DIABETES 46% OF
OUR STATE HAS PRE DIABETES.
THAT CONSUMING ONE SUGARY DRINK
A DAY IS BASICALLY SAYING YOU'RE
GOING TO DEVELOP DIABETES --
THAT THAT IS CONTRIBUTING TO AN
ALREADY RISK ALREADY HIGH RISK
POPULATION AND 46% OF OUR STATE
IS A MATTER THAT STATUS IN
ADDITION IT DOUBLES THE RISK OF
CAVITIES.
SO WHAT FOCUSING ON OBESITY IS
CONVENIENT BECAUSE CERTAINLY
PEOPLE WHO ARE OBESE STRUGGLE
LOSING WEIGHT WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT SO PEOPLE MAKE CONTINUE OR
MAY EVEN STOP DRINKING BUT STILL
MAY NOT LOSE WEIGHT AND SO
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY
THERE'S A TIME LAG.
IN CDC DATA LOOKING AT
CONSUMPTION AND OBESITY WE ARE
GOING TO IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME
FOR THESE THINGS TO HAPPEN THEY
DON'T HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY UP AT
THE SAME TIME THAT YOU STOPPED
DRINKING A BEVERAGE.
THAT YOUR WEIGHT SUDDENLY
BECOMES NORMAL BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE ALSO NOT RECOGNIZING
THAT OBESITY IS BUT ONE OF THE
THREE THINGS THAT ARE CALLED OUT
ON THE LABEL AS BEING A DIRECT
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS.
THINGS THAT ARE HARMING THE
HEALTH AND AS WE AS WE SHOWN
THERE ARE DAY EIGHT A SHOWING
THAT PARENTS WHEN THEY ARE WHEN
THEY SEE A WARNING LABEL AS
COMPARED TO THAT CLEAR ON
CALORIES.
THAT THE EVERY BEVERAGE INDUSTRY
DID THAT THEY ACTUALLY DO BEGIN
TO RECOGNIZE AND MAKE THOSE
CHANGES AND SO THAT'S THE DATA
COMPONENT OF IT THAT IS MISSING
AND IN THE ARGUMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER MESS
[inaudible]
SO.
I'M I'M STRUGGLING ACTUALLY THE
DISK SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
ARE BEING MADE -- BOTH PRO AND
CON SEEMED TO TO LEAVE ME
WANTING -- FOR FOR MORE --
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW FINANCED
SOLELY BY THE MANUFACTURES
ARGUMENT BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT A SENATOR THAT THOSE
LABELS.
GET CHANGE ON A REGULAR BASIS --
I DO STRUGGLE AND WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY -- WITH --
WHY THE LABELS WHAT WHY WE
CHOOSE -- SOME PRODUCTS AND NOT.
ALL THE PRODUCTS -- ONE OF THEM
BEING CHOCOLATE MILK -- I SHARED
WITH YOU -- LE STORY HAVE A VERY
CLOSE FRIEND AND IT'S A
PEDIATRIC DENTIST AND SO -- I
OFTEN TIMES WE'LL SEE A MOUTH
FULL OF FROM KIDS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY -- CARRIES WRITTEN --
AND THREE YEARS OLD FOUR YEARS
OLD.
AND IT'S BECAUSE MOMS THINKING
THAT -- CHOCOLATE MILK THAT HAS
ORGANIC ON THE LABEL IS HEALTHY
FOR THEIR KIDS JUST BECAUSE THE
WAY THAT IT'S LABELED IT SAYS
ORGANIC AND THEY THINK OSIS
HEALTHY IT'S IT'S MILK IT'S GOT
A NUTRITIONAL VALUE WHEN IN FACT.
IT ISN'T HEALTHY FOR THE KIDS
THE IT'S APPLE JUICE IS NOT.
JUICE IS NOT HELD IS OUR
NUTRITIONAL VALUE YES -- BUT IT
ISN'T -- HEALTHY A FOR KIDS ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE HEALTHY BUT
THEY'RE NOT IT'S NOT ALL HEALTHY
I THINK OF OF OF THE AMERICAN
DIET MY DIET I DRINK A KNOW
SUGARED SODAS.
DIET COKE EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE A
DIET COKE ISN'T GOING TO BE
LABELED BUT I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
THAT A DIET COKE IS HEALTHY. FOR
ME BUT THIS LABEL WHAT BE ON A
ON A DIET COKE BUT IT WOULD BE
ON A ON A COCA COLA THAT'S
THAT'S THERE.
AND SO I I WONDER IF THIS IS
REALLY -- WHAT WE -- IT IS THE
ANSWER -- THE ONE QUESTION IF I
CAN ACTUALLY TO A TO THE TO THE
OPPOSITION I ASK THIS THIS
QUESTION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE THAT THE
TAX ON SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
BUT BECAUSE DURING THAT TIME I
ASKED THE QUESTION WELL -- IF IT
TAX ISN'T THE ANSWER BUT WHAT'S
THE ANSWER WILL EDUCATION IS THE
ANSWER.
WHAT WHAT HOW DO WE DO EDUCATION
THEN IF IT'S NOT WITH THE LABEL
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THE LABEL
IN OF ITSELF AS THE BEST LABEL --
TOOK TO LIST ON ON A CAN BUT HOW
DO WE EDUCATE PEOPLE THAT --
THAT THERE YOU'RE TAKING AND
THAT MUCH SUGAR WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE DRINKING A COKE OR OR A
PEPSI -- HOW DO WE EDUCATE
PEOPLE THAT THAT BANANA NOT MOM
A MUFFIN AT STARBUCKS HAS A TON
OF SUGAR INTO THAT YOU SHOULDN'T
BE EATING HOW DO WE?
HOW DO WE EDUCATE IF THIS ISN'T
THE ANSWER THEN THEN WHAT AT
WHAT POINT DOES THE INDUSTRY
WHAT WHAT IS IT THE INDUSTRY
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE?
OF IT IS TO TO GET THE WORD OUT
THAT PEOPLE ARE CONSUMING. TOO
MUCH SUGAR -- THAT THAT IT IS
HAVING AN IMPACT ON TYPE TWO
DIABETES-- IT IS HAVING AN
IMPACT ON TWO TWO K. -- WHAT IS
THE ANSWER IF IF THE LABEL -- IS
IS NOT A SOME OF OUR WORKING.
JOHN LET IT RUN HAVE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION OF PEPSICO --
I DO THINK.
THAT THE PROBLEM THAT THAT YOU
POSE.
AS SOMEONE MAKE MAZES IS REAL
AND IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR ALL OF
US I DO THINK THE MOVE TOWARDS
CLEAR ON CALORIES AS AN ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO BE CLEAR WITH
CONSUMERS ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE
CONSUMING.
IN TERMS OF CALORIC INTAKE I DO
THINK THE PROBLEM YOU KNOW IT IS
GOES BACK EVEN TO A MISTER
MCCARTY WAS TALKING ABOUT IF WE
ASKED MOST KIDS AND PROBABLY
THREE ASKED ALL THE MEMBERS FROM
THE DíAS WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T
KNOW WHAT OUR IDEAL CALORIC
INTAKE FOR EACH ONE OF US.
IS.
SO PART OF THE PROBLEM IS NOT
JUST SIMPLY THAT -- DO I KNOW
WHAT'S IN THAT PRODUCT TO DO I
KNOW OF THAT OF OF THAT HOW MUCH
I'M SUPPOSED TO HAVE THIS LABEL
DOESN'T GIVE ANY INFORMATION.
CORD THAT IT JUST SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THAT PRODUCT IS HARMFUL
DOESN'T SAY HOW IT'S HARMFUL --
SO IT JUST SAYS IT HAS ADDED
SUGARS I MEAN EVERYTHING HAS
ADDED SUGARS IS HARMFUL -- I
DON'T HAVE A GOOD ANSWER FOR YOU
I KNOW WHAT THE INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN DOING THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY GOING FORTH IN
BRINGING OUT NEW PRODUCTS.
AND WE AGAIN AS I SAID BEORE WE
NOW HAVE 50% OF THE PRODUCTS
SOLD OUR ZERO CALORIE PRODUCTS
THAT IS A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
CONSUMERS WANT.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN IN
MAGICALLY COMING UP WITH A
PUBLIC POLICY FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SAYS THIS IS WHY
WE KNOW EVERYBODY WILL HAVE THE
RIGHT BIT OF INFORMATION --
THAT'S HARD AND I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR THAT.
SORRY THIS IS.
LEAVING YOU WANTING BUT THIS
WARNING LABEL THAT WE'RE
DESCRIBING ALSO DOESN'T HAVE
INFORMATION FOR THE CONSUMER
JUST SIMPLY TELL THEM NOT TO
TOUCH A CERTAIN PRODUCT.
THERE'S NO CONTEXT FOR WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT OR HOW MUCH
OF IT THAT THEY SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT MY SUPPOSED TO HAVE
TWO THOUSAND CALORIES A TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IF I EXERCISE A LITTLE BIT OR A
LOT ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
FACTORS.
THAT GO INTO WHAT YOU SHOULD
CONSUME OF ANY PRODUCT WITH
CALORIES NOT JUST THIS PRODUCT
WITH CALORIES.
IS IT.
CENTERED.
SHOULD THIS BE DONE ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL -- TO HAVE SOME
MA'AM IS THIS SOMETHING THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE DOING BACK BACK
IN WASHINGTON THAT SPREAD ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHAT WHY CALIFORNIA
WHY SHOULD WE BE SPECIAL -- WITH
THIS WELL IT'S A FAIR QUESTION
WE HAVE A UNIQUE PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE TRENDS OF
PREVENTABLE TYPE TWO DIABETES
WE'VE ALSO BEEN A PIONEER IN
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH.
AREAS I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
WAITING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ACT WOULD BE
TANTAMOUNT. TO NOT TAKING ACTION
ON WHAT IS A PROVEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EPIDEMIC AND IF I MIGHT
JUST THROUGH THE CHAIR ADDRESS
THE OTHER PART OF YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTED TO THE INDUSTRY TO
PLEASE YOU THANK YOU -- SO THE
CHOCOLATE MILK CONSUMPTION WHICH
WE DESCRIBED THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE I'M NOT HERE'S A
PROPONENT OF CHOCOLATE MILK FOR
CHILDREN THERE IS PROTEIN IN
MILK PRODUCTS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF BEVERAGES
THAT WOULD EARN THIS LABEL.
HAVE NO NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
IN MANY ARE DISGUISED VITAMIN
WATER THAT A PARENT MIGHT BUY
FOR THEIR CHILD THINKING.
GREAT VITAMIN WATERING TO MAKE
SURE MY CHILD HAS ALL OF HIS OR
HER VITAMINS.
THOSE PRODUCTS INCLUDE SUGARS TO
THE LEVEL THAT WOULD EARN THE
LABEL ON THE OPPONENT ARGUES
THAT THE LABEL WOULD STIGMATIZE
THE PRODUCT AND NOBODY WOULD BUY
IT -- I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
BE THE RESULT AS I SAID EARLIER.
THE LABEL DOESN'T RAISE THE COST
IT DOESN'T REMOVE IT FROM FROM
THE MARKET PLACE IT INFORMS
CHOICE SOME PEOPLE.
MAY INFORMED CHOICE.
THEY MAY EXERCISE MORE
MODERATION.
THEY MAY CHOOSE ONLY TO BUY
THOSE BEVERAGES FOR A SPECIAL
OCCASION AS OPPOSED TO A STAPLE
IN THE DIET.
SO I THINK [inaudible]
WE CAN.
SPLIT HAIRS AS TO WHAT'S COVERED
WHAT'S NOT COVERED SCIENCE NOT
POLITICIANS HAVE CONCLUDED.
THAT THE CONSUMPTION.
OF LIQUID SUGAR IS METABOLIZED
IN A DIFFERENT MANNER THAN SUGAR
THE TEEN FOOD PRODUCTS.
THAT THE BODY DIGESTS ELIMINATES.
THE LIQUID SUGAR.
MAKES THE PANCREAS THE KIDNEYS
WORK OVERTIME CONVERTS THAT
SUGAR TO FAT.
MESSENGER JUST ONE MORE QUESTION
TO TALK ABOUT THE LABELING AND
IN A SPLITTING HAIRS I THINK OF
SMOOTHIES -- I THINK THERE'S I'M
THINKING OF ON WALL OF BEING ONE
ONE BRAND -- THAT THERE ARE LOTS
OF FRUIT AND IN THEM HI
NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
BUT SOME OF THEM HAVE ADDED
SUGARS THAT WILL BE REQUIRED TO
HAVE A LABEL AND MAYBE THERE IS
ONE THAT -- THE DOESN'T HAVE
ADDED SUGARS WOULDN'T HAVE THE
LABEL BUT ACTUALLY COULD HAVE A
HIGHER SUGAR SUGAR CONTENT.
ARE WE WELL THERE IS THE LABEL
IS BASED ON ADDED SUGAR --
FRUCTOSE SUGAR IT'S IT'S WHAT IS
CALCULATED.
IT WOULD CAPTURE THE SPORTY'S%
THE ENERGY DRINKS AT CETERA.
WEEK SAM DAIRY PRODUCTS AGAIN ON
THE THEORY THAT DAIRY PRODUCTS
HAVE NUTRITIONAL VALUE IN
PROTEIN SOMEBODY ASKED WHAT
ABOUT ALCOHOL ARE YOU GONNA PUT
THIS LABEL ON ALCOHOL OTHERS
HIGH CONCENTRATIONS.
OF SUGAR AND ALCOHOL YOU HAVE TO
BE TWENTY ONE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
BUY ALCOHOL -- WE DO KERRY LABEL
WARNINGS TO PROTECT PREGNANT
WOMEN.
ON ALCOHOL PRODUCTS WERE REALLY
FOCUSED ON A HEALTH EPIDEMIC
AMONG CHILDREN.
THAT MY WIFE WAS A PUBLIC HEALTH
PHYSICIAN REMINDS ME WHAT USED
TO BE CALLED ADULT ONSET
DIABETES.
IT'S NO LONGER CALLED ADULT
ONSET WE'RE SEEING AND TEENAGERS
AND PRETEENS.
AGAIN THIS ISN'T THE SOLUTION.
BUT IT'S PART OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
STRATEGY SUPPORTED BY ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS YOU HEARD TODAY
WHO REPRESENT YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
EVERY DAY IN THE SCHOOLS.
IN THE CLINICS -- IN IT'S A
CHOICE OF THOSE CONSTITUENTS.
OVER DISTRIBUTORS OF THESE
PRODUCTS WHO WILL NOT GO OUT OF
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
CINNAMON I'D LIKE.
TO I'M SORRY MISTER NAZARIAN I'M
SORRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIKE I
SAID I DIDN'T WANT TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS TO ME
THIS IS PRETTY CLEAR CUT.
BUT LISTENING TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS WHICH WHO.
VERY MUCH VALUE AND RESPECT THE
INPUT THAT THEY'RE PLACING ON
THIS BUT I FEEL LIKE WE ASK
QUESTIONS SOMETIMES TO DISSECT
AN ISSUE.
WHERE WE HAVE DIRECT CORRELATION
OF WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON SO WHAT
I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE ON IS?
FROM THE DOCTOR MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU DON'T MIND CAN YOU PLEASE.
EXPLAINED THE CORRELATION OF THE
STRINGS WITH THE IMPACT THEY'RE
HAVING ON DIABETES AND CAN YOU
PLEASE PUT NUMBERS AGAIN.
VERY BRIEFLY.
BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT THAT CORRELATION WE CAN
DISSECT THE ISSUES WE CAN ASK
WHY.
SOMETHINGS ARE NOT INCLUDED WHY
OTHER THINGS ARE INCLUDED BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE START FROM
ONE PLACE.
AND WE WORK TO EXPAND FROM THERE
RIGHT NOW THIS IS THE BILL WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US.
THIS ISSUE IS IMPACTING SOME OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
AND SO I WANT TO HEAR THE
NUMBERS.
IF YOU I'M HAPPY TO RATTLE OFF
FOR YOU AS WELL BUT IF YOU LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND THE FIRST SAY
THE DIRECT CORRELATION.
OF WHY WE'RE DOING THIS AND THE
NUMBERS THAT IT IMPACTS
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO SO
TO BE VERY CLEAR WE ARE IN A
STATE WHERE 46% OF THE
POPULATION HAS PRE DIABETES OKAY
AND ANOTHER 9% HAS DIABETES SO
55% OF OUR STATE'S POPULATION.
EITHER HAS DIABETES OR IS IN THE
PIPELINE AND SO CONSUMING ONE
SUGARY DRINK A DAY INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING CAVITIES BY
1100% IT DOUBLES YOUR LIKELIHOOD
OF HAVING CAVITIES. ONE SUGARY
DRINK A DAY AMONG CHILDREN
INCREASES THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF
BEING OBESE BY 55%. ONE SUGARY
DRINK PER DAY INCREASES THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF DIABETES BY 26%
AND IN ADULTS LIKELIHOOD OF
DIABETES BY 27%.
THOSE ARE THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
SO IT ISN'T WHAT WE FOCUS ON
SURE THEIR SUGAR AND LOTS OF
THINGS WE CAN HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE HAVE A
SCIENTIFIC BASIS TO SHOW THE
LINK BETWEEN SUGARY DRINKS AND
THE HEALTH OUTCOMES THAT ARE
INCLUDED ON THE LABEL.
DO YOU WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU DON'T MIND.
THANK YOU DO YOU WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THIS
IMPACTS.
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISPANIC.
OF OF THE COMMUNITIES.
WHOEVER ELSE YOU WANT INCLUDING
YOUR DEMOGRAPHIC BREAKDOWN
ABSOLUTELY SO ONE OF THE THE
THINGS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE IS THAT WITHIN
CALIFORNIA -- MEMBERS OF OUR OUR
FIRST NATION ARE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ARE BLACK
COMMUNITIES IN A LATINO
COMMUNITIES HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF DIABETES -- AND
THAT FOR CHILDREN BORN SINCE THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND ONE IN TWO
BLACK AND LATINO CHILDREN ARE
SLATED TO DEVELOP DIABETES IN
THEIR LIFETIME THAT'S 50% OF
BOTH OF THOSE POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN BORN BETTER.
AGE NINETEEN AND UNDER RIGHT NOW
ARE SLATED TO DEVELOP DIABETES
WHEN THE WORD EPIDEMIC IS THROWN
AROUND SO OFTEN AND I'M AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST BY TRAINING AND
SO I'M REALLY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
USING THAT WORD.
WHEN WE START TALKING ABOUT ONE
IN TWO CHILDREN BORN AFTER A
CERTAIN AGE BASICALLY EVERYONE
NINETEEN AND UNDER -- THAT IS
THE DEFINITION OF AN EPIDEMIC --
YOU COULD NOT DESCRIBE IT IN ANY
OTHER WAY THAT IT THAT MEANS
THAT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
PRODUCTIVITY WE THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW WELLNESS WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THEIR LIFE EXPECTANCY --
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT HAMPERING
OF THEIR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
GROW UP AND BE HEALTHY ADULTS
SORRY SAY THAT AGAIN.
WHAT'S THE DEFINITION OF AN
EPIDEMIC AND WHAT THRESHOLD MUST
THAT PASS SO TYPICALLY WE START
TALKING ABOUT EPIDEMICS WHEN AT
LEAST 15% OF THE POPULATION IS
AFFECTED.
AND WHERE ARE WE NOW WITH THIS
WE ARE AT ONE INTO BLACK AND
LATINO CHILDREN BORN AFTER THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND WILL LIKELY
DEVELOP DIABETES.
SO TO THE OPPOSITION.
WITH THERE WAS THIS WAS BEFORE
MY TIME HERE BUT THERE WAS SO
MANY ISSUES AND CONCERNS ABOUT.
OF FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS
PROVIDING CALORIC INTAKE NUMBERS --
I I DON'T EVEN KNOW MAYBE YOU
WORKED ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES --
AT I DON'T WANT TO ASSUME.
THERE WAS SO MUCH CONSTERNATION
OVER THAT ISSUE THERE WAS SO
MANY ATTEMPTS BUT THEN
ULTIMATELY IT PASSED.
AND IT'S BEEN WORKING GREAT.
NEVER IN MY LIFETIME THAT I
THINK MCDONALD'S WOULD BE
OFFERING SALADS.
IT IS.
MAYBE IT HAD SOME VERSION OF A
SALAD IN THE PAST AS WELL BUT
THERE HAS BEEN A TREND THAT'S
HELPED PUSH SO WHEN I HEAR THE
QUESTION WHAT DOES THIS BILL DO.
IT'LL EXACTLY DO WHAT IT FORCED
TO HAPPEN IN THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY -- WHICH IS HEALTHIER
OUTCOMES.
NONE OF THE BUSINESSES SHUT DOWN.
NONE OF THE FAST FOOD PLACES
WENT AWAY [inaudible]
THEY'RE THRIVING.
AND EVEN DOING A GREAT JOB BUT
AT LEAST THE PRODUCT THAT
THEY'VE BEEN.
SERVING HAS IMPROVED OVER TIME.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THESE
BUSINESSES ARE GONNA GO AWAY OR
BE IMPACTED.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO CHANGE
THEIR MODEL.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WE EVOLVE AND
WE IMPROVE.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE
WORK ON THOSE ISSUES.
WE EVOLVE AND WE CHANGE AND WE
IMPROVE OUR STANDARDS.
SO.
WHEN I SEE THESE NUMBERS AND
WHEN I SEE THE NUMBERS AT THE U.
S. LEVEL?
BASIC MATH AGAIN 300-27 MILLION
US POPULATION NINETY THREE
MILLION ARE IMPACTED BY DIABETES.
THAT'S 28% OF OUR POPULATION.
AND IT'S HIGHER IN CALIFORNIA.
I MEAN IF WE THINK WE HAVE COSTS
RIGHT NOW BETWEEN ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
GOING FORWARD NEXT TWENTY YEARS
IF WE DON'T TRY TO ADDRESS THEM
RIGHT NOW.
AND OUR AGING POPULATION AND AS
WE AGE WE HAVE MORE NEUROLOGICAL
ISSUES THAT CURRENTLY.
ELDER POPULATION IS NOT GETTING
TO AN AGE TO DIE FROM BUT WILL
BE DYING FROM SOON ENOUGH.
WITH ALL OF THESE IMPACT.
HOW ARE WE EVEN GONNA BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN?
THE HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR
STATE AND THIS IS JUST ONE OF
THE VERY BASIC WAYS.
THAT WE CAN HELP CURB STARTING
TODAY SO THAT IN TWENTY YEARS
TIME WE SEE THE IMPROVEMENTS
JUST LIKE HOW THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY.
DID THOSE CHANGES WERE MADE
ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO ROUGHLY
TEN YEARS AGO.
AND WE'RE WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENT.
SO I THINK THIS IS.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL --
AND A I SUPPORTED AND I DO HOPE
THAT MY COLLEAGUES SUPPORT THIS
AS A INCREMENTAL STEP.
TOWARDS IMPROVING HEALTH CARE
OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SHERMAN MAY I THOUGHT IT WAS A
QUESTION TO AT ONE POINT IN THAT
I THOUGHT THERE WAS A QUESTION
TO THE OPPOSITION WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE WORKED ON THEM MENU
LABELLING RESTAURANTS I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THAT.
MISTER MISTER WHICH THERE WAS
RUSSIAN -- ACTUALLY VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT AT FOR AND I
THINK THE KEY POINT -- MISSION
IS ARIAN AS THE INFORMATION THAT
WAS BEING REQUIRED OF
RESTAURANTS IS EXACTLY THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ON A
CONTAINER TODAY.
IT WAS A FULL MENU A FULL
CALORIC IMPACT THE FULL YOU KNOW
WHAT IS IN THE MAKE UP OF THE
PRODUCT PACKAGE PRODUCTS HAVE
ALWAYS HAD THAT KNOWS THE
ARGUMENT IS THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME -- INFORMATION IS PACKAGED
FOOD DOES SO.
I'M NOT ARGUING AGAINST THAT IT
BROUGHT THE IT BROUGHT THE FAST
FOOD AND ALL FOOD INDUSTRY ALL
RESTAURANTS UP TO THE SAME LEVEL
AS WHAT THAT CONTAINER NOW HOLES
THERE WAS NOT A WARNING LABEL.
ABOUT ANY OF THE ELEMENTS BEING
CONSUMED IT THAT FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT IT WAS THE SAME
INFORMATION IT'S ON THE PACKAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DON'T
WANT TO GO BACK AND FORTH TOO
MUCH.
I THINK IF THAT WAS THE CASE WE
WOULD HAVE ALSO SEEN -- LESS
IMPACTS HAPPENING.
OVER THE OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
I I DON'T THINK THAT'S
NECESSARILY THE CASE I THINK.
THE MORE INFORMATION WE PROVIDE
THE MORE TRANSPARENCY WE PROVIDE
THE MORE LABELING WE PROVIDE.
A FACT THERE IS A QUESTION ABOUT
HOW -- DIET COKE WON'T BE
IMPACTED BY THIS WELL THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF LABELING THAT
TALKS ABOUT THE SUGAR YOU THE
SWEETENER USED IN DIET COKE CAN
CAUSE OTHER HARMS.
AND SO IT MAKES PEOPLE A LOT
MORE CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT WHETHER
THEY WANT.
TO YOU.
DO YOU YOU REALIZE IT OR NOT SO --
I THINK THE MORE INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED THE BETTER IT IS AND
AND I THINK WE CAN ONLY STAND TO
IN PROOF.
BOTH ARE HEALTHCARE OUTCOMES AS
WELL AS INVIGORATING.
AND REINVIGORATING ARE OUR OUR
PRODUCERS TO OF OF PROVIDE
BETTER UP HEALTHIER ALTERNATIVES
RATHER THAN CONTINUING DOWN THE
SAME LINE AND SAYING THIRD
DOESN'T NEED TO BE ANY CHANGE.
WE CONSTANTLY CHANGE AND IMPROVE
AND IT'S NOT GONNA HURT ANY
BUSINESS MODEL TO CHANGE AND
IMPROVE THEIR PRODUCT NOW ON IN
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
YEAH I WANNA THANK ALL THREE ON
FOR FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION FOR TO GET
ENOUGH SLEEP THIS IS YOUR
PROBABLY SECOND THIRD TIME
AROUND OF THINKING ABOUT.
AND I KNOW WE TALKED -- BRIEFLY
THE OTHER DAY ABOUT -- THE
ISSUES WITH SUGAR AND AND THE
INCREASE OF DIABETES OBESITY I
GET IT DON'T HAVE TO TELL ME.
BUT THE PROBLEM WANTS ON HAVE IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS LAST COUPLE
YEARS IT SEEMS LIKE.
OF THE DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
TALKED.
ABOUT THE INCREASES OF OF ALL
THE SAME BECAUSE OF SODAS SUGARY
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
AND IT SEEMS BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASE IS BECAUSE OF THAT I'M
GONNA TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT SORE
ABOUT MYSELF PRIOR TO FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
WORKING IN THE ALBUMS INDUSTRY
FOR IT'S BEEN OVER THIRTY YEARS
NOW.
AND I COULD SEE THIS GOING BACK
OVER TEN YEARS OUT THERE THAT.
WE STARTED TO SEE THE INCREASE
OF OBESITY AND DIABETES BACK
THEN BUT IT WAS NEVER BECAUSE OF
SUGAR IT WAS NEVER BECAUSE OUR
KIDS ARE DRINKING SUGAR IT WAS
JUST SOMETHING WHAT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING WHETHER IT'S
PEOPLE ARE BEING AS HEALTHY AS
THEY SHOULD BE?
THE DISCUSSION WAS NEVER ABOUT
THAT FAST FOR TWO NOW IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE SINGLING OUT.
ONE OUR LOCAL INDUSTRY OR ONE
ONE TYPE OF MANUFACTURE WHAT
WE'RE PRODUCING AS A SOUL
BECAUSE OF IT AND IT'S NOT THEY
COULD BE PART OF IT YEAH DON'T
GET ME WRONG.
BUT WE LOOK AT THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON WHY.
WE SEE THAT BIG INCREASE IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING FOR YEARS I'VE
WORKED IN THE FIELD I'VE TAKEN
MANY PATIENTS ALSO DOES.
AND I'VE SEEN IT.
OVER TEN YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
PART OF COMING UP HERE.
SO LATELY WHEN I HEAR THAT
DISCUSSION MAKES ME.
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WERE BEING
HEARD ABOUT.
ON ANOTHER ISSUE ON THE TALK
ABOUT MY DAUGHTER I DON'T WANT
TO SPECIFICALLY NAME THE PLACE
WHERE SHE WORKS.
BUT SHE WORKS AT A PLACE WHERE
THEY SELL -- COFFEE.
AND I WAS RECENTLY THERE
WATCHING OR SHOES AT WORK
BECAUSE SHE WOULD TELL ME.
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT SOME OF THESE
KIDS ARE COMING WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND THEY'LL GET A DRINK IN THE
AD PUMPS OF SIR SHE WAS YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH A POMPOUS YOUR PALS.
AND THE FAMILIES IN THE MOTHERS
ARE WITH THEM AND THEY'LL TAKE
FIVE TO TEN POUNDS AND I'VE SEEN
THEM.
KIDS OF ALL COLORS AND RACES.
AND I'M LIKE WOW BUT YET WE
DON'T LOOK AT THAT AS AN ISSUE.
BUT WE LOOK MORE ABOUT A SUGARY
BEVERAGE -- I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTIES WITH THIS BILL.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF IT BUT I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON HOW WE BRING
OUR YOUTH.
THE STARTS AT HOME WITH OUR
PARENTS OUR FAMILIES OR MOTHERS
FATHERS OF FAMILY MEMBERS AND
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO WE NOT ONLY
SUGAR BUT EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
WE DO.
I THINK NOWADAYS SOME OF OUR
KIDS DON'T LIKE TO BE HEALTHY IN
GOING OUT AND DOING EXTRA
CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES WHETHER BE
PLAYING.
BASEBALL FOOTBALL BASS MIGHT
KEEP THE MOTIVATED DO THINGS
AFTER SCHOOL INSTEAD OF JUST
COMING HOME AND MAYBE JUST
SITTING ON THE IPHONE OR IPAD.
AND NOT BEING HEALTHY THAT WAY
AS WELL BUT WE JUST TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY DRINK I THINK IT'S
MORE THAN JUST THAT IT'S A
BIGGER PROBLEM THAT WE'RE HAVING
OUT THERE TO OUR UPBRINGING.
BUT ALSO TO HOME WITH OUR
PARENTS RIGHT HOW DO WE EDUCATE
OUR KIDS TO EAT AND DRINK
HEALTHY ALTERNATIVES WITH THAT
SO JUST SOMETHING I JUST WANTED
TO THROW OUT THERE. TO THE FOLKS
AND I'M HAVING DIFFICULTIES
CENTER SO MAY NOT BE LOOKING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE I JUST LIKE TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AND I'LL GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE SENATOR--
SO I'M PREVENTION OR IN BY
NATURE IT'S MY TRAINING -- MY
EXPERIENCE MY CAREER.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT
PREVENTION FOR AND LOOKING AT
LONG TERM HEALTH LATELY IT'S
ABOUT WILDFIRES WHICH IS ABOUT
LONG TERM HEALTH -- I BELIEVE AS
WELL -- IT WAS POINTED OUT I
THINK.
QUESTION BY MR MAYES -- ASKING
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD TACKLE THIS
AT A NATIONAL LEVEL MAYBE WE
SHOULD BE DOING THIS A
CALIFORNIA -- AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT SOMETHING THAT'S THAT
THAT THAT'S INTERESTING THAT I I
LEARNED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
WE IN CALIFORNIA DO NOT INVEST
MUCH MONEY.
IN RESEARCH OR NOT RESEARCH BUT
I'M PROGRAMS RELATED TO DIABETES
EDUCATION WE DON'T.
WE SPEND VERY VERY LITTLE.
NOW THE STATE IN NEW YORK ON THE
OTHER HAND.
INVESTED A WHOLE BUNCH AND GUESS
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE NET THE THE INCIDENCE OF
DIABETES AND PRE DISS THE THAT
PRE DIABETES HAS HAS DECREASED.
SO WE HAD A BILL IN HERE --
AWHILE BACK -- ASSEMBLY BILL THE%
TAXED THAT THAT CREATED TAX TO
CREATE REVENUE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
OF THAT AND THAT BILL PASSES
COMMITTEE -- AFTER IT WAS THE
THIRD TIME I'M TRYING TO GET
THAT BILL PASSED BUT IT IT
DIDN'T MAKE IT OUT ANOTHER
COMMITTEE -- AND AND THAT THAT'S
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE I I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS --
OVER THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ON BEHALF ON AND
YOUR PERSISTENCE ON BEHALF OF OF
CALIFORNIANS.
ON BILLS RELATED TO SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES ON WANTING
TO ADDRESS THE OBESITY EPIDEMIC.
AS WE HEARD OBESITY -- IMPACTS
OVER NINETY THREE MILLION ADULTS
AMERICANS EXCUSE ME ADULTS AND
CHILDREN ALIKE SKEWS ME.
OBESITY RELATED CONDITIONS LIKE
HEART DISEASE STROKE -- TYPE THE
TYPE TWO DIABETES AND CERTAIN
TYPES OF CANCER ARE SOME OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF PREVENTABLE.
AND PREMATURE DEATHS IN THESE
CONDITIONS ARE MADE WORSE.
BY THE CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES NOT SAYING
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY COSTS AND
AND I WILL BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
THAT.
BUT THESE ARE THINGS THAT
EXACERBATE CONDITIONS AND AND
MAKE MAKE THEM WORSE -- THESE
CONDITIONS AT THE CONDITIONS ARE
COSTING THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- AND
TAKING A PERSONAL TOLL ON
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN OUR LACK
OF DRIVE TO INVEST IN EDUCATION --
LEADS US TO SPEND MONEY -- IN
AND HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA ON TREATMENT OF
DIABETES LIKE INSULIN.
LIKE WOUND CARE LIKE PROSTHETICS
SOMETIMES BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
AMPUTATE -- AMPUTATE AND THEN
PEOPLE DIE PREMATURELY -- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE LOTS OF FOODS
THAT HAVE LABELS OUT THERE --
AND I TIED TEND TO LOOK AT THEM
AND I LOOK AT LABELS AS A WAY TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE -- YOU GO TO THIS
YOU GO TO THE SUPER WHILE
RABIN'S IN YOU SEE SALT.
LOW SALT.
OR DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING SO I'M
GONNA SEEM AT THAT POINT AS
PRIDE GOT MORE SALT IN IT LOW
FAT WHEN IS SOON THE ONES THAT
ARE MAYBE HAVE MORE FAT.
OF VEGAN.
VEGETARIAN.
THESE ARE THINGS OUT THERE AND
SO.
SOME FOOD MANUFACTURERS OF HAVE
FIGURED OUT A WAY TO USE THE
LABELS AS MARKETING. TO ATTRACT
PEOPLE OR GIVE THEM THE OPTIONS.
TO TO HAVE AND CONSUME IN IT IN
A DIFFERENT WAY -- AND YEAH
MAYBE THE INDUSTRY COULD BE
CHALLENGED TO DO THAT.
PUT IT OUT THERE YOU DON'T LET
PEOPLE KNOW BECAUSE THEY ARE
GOING TO CONSUME THINGS PEOPLE
GO TO CONVENIENCE STORES I GO TO
GAS STATIONS AND THEY'RE GONNA
CONSUME THINGS IT'S SUMMERTIME
IT.
IT'S A HUNDRED DEGREES OUTSIDE
NOT TODAY BUT IT WILL BE.
AN PEOPLE GONNA CONSUME THINGS
THERE BUT LET HIM KNOW THAT
THEIR WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S IN
THERE AND MAYBE MAYBE WILL
CHOOSE TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.
AND I WAS IN MEXICO A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO AND I SAW -- AND
AIRPORT COMING BACK -- LABELS ON
CIGARETTES.
SCARE THE HECK OUT OF A PERSON
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT'S ON THOSE
BECAUSE THEIR PICTURES WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU SMOKE
CIGARETTES.
WE HAVE A U. S. SURGE SURGEON
GENERAL'S WARNING LABEL ON
CIGARETTES TO SAY SMOKING
CIGARETTES CAN CAUSE CANCER AND
DEATH -- WE'RE EDUCATING PEOPLE
AND THAT'S HOW I LOOK THAT'S HOW
I LOOK AT LABELS SO -- I THINK
WE NEED -- TO TAKE A STAND ON
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE I THINK LABELING INCREASES
AWARENESS.
IT WAS PEOPLE THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT IS THEY'RE ABOUT TO BUY JUST
LIKE WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOOD IN THE CALORIC INTAKE
PEOPLE LOOK AT THESE THINGS NOW.
SO I GUESS WHAT IS INDUSTRY
AFRAID OF USE IT AS A MARKETING
TOOL IF YOU WISH -- SO I
UNDERSTAND.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT -- YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE THIS BILL SB THREE FORTY
SEVEN A TO YOUR BILL.
AND SO WE WON'T BE TAKING A VOTE
ON THIS TODAY.
BUT I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE CENTER MONEY.
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. FOR AN ISSUE THAT'S
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY.
AND I THINK JUST KEEN ON ON SOME
OF YOUR COMMENTS.
THE INDUSTRY.
IS.
MARKETING ZERO CALORIE ZERO
SUGAR BEVERAGES -- THEY SEE THE
WRITING ON THE WALL BUT THEY'RE
STILL.
AGGRESSIVELY MARKETING SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES WITH ADDED
SUGARS THEIR MARKETING THEM WITH
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR AD
CAMPAIGNS WE DON'T INVEST IN
PREVENTION WE DON'T INVEST IN A
MANNER.
THAT CAN COMPETE WITH THE
INDUSTRY'S ADVERTISING THEY'RE
TARGETING OF MINORITY
COMMUNITIES OF YOUNG PEOPLE --
WE HEARD FROM A WITNESS TODAY OF
OF GROWING UP IN HER COMMUNITY
IN TRYING TO MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES.
YOU CITED MISTER CHAIR THE USE
OF LABELS EFFECTIVELY IN
MARKETING AND ALSO IN PROTECTION.
SO MEMBERS.
THIS WE DON'T PICK.
ON SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE AN EASY
TARGET WE PICK ON SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES BECAUSE
SCIENCE NOT POLITICIANS HAS
DETERMINED.
THAT THEY'RE NOT ONLY.
EMPTY CALORIES THEIR NEGATIVE
CALORIE STATE DO DAMAGE.
THE INCREASE DENTAL CAVITIES
YOUR CHANCE BY 1100%.
THAT'S WHY THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS TRY THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HAS BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER THIS.
IT'S WHY NURSES PTA PARENTS
TEACHERS COACHES.
ON ALL OF THOSE IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES WE'RE TRYING TO
RAISE HEALTHY FAMILIES AND
HEALTHY CHILDREN.
AND YET UNFORTUNATELY.
THE POWER OF THIS INDUSTRY.
IS INFLUENCING A HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THAT SHOULD BE HERE TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE YOU
REPRESENT.
SO IT'S WITH GREAT REGRET.
THAT WE HAVE FALLEN SHORT OF THE
NECESSARY VOTES TODAY. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE. TO
TAKE A STEP THAT IS SUPPORTED BY
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES.
BY DOCTORS BY NURSES.
BY YOUNG PEOPLE ADVOCATES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE OF THE RATIONALE IN THE
RATIONALIZATIONS.
PUT FORWARD BY AN INDUSTRY.
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MANUFACTURE THESE PRODUCTS THE
WILL CONTINUE TO HIRE WORKERS IN
YOUR DISTRICTS [inaudible]
IN YET [inaudible]
THE CHILDREN.
THAT ARE THE VICTIMS OF THIS
EPIDEMIC.
IT'S NOT ME SAYING IT'S AN
EPIDEMIC IT'S A SCIENTIFIC TERM.
HELD.
BY THE OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL.
PREVENTABLE DIABETES IS EPIDEMIC.
IT'S MULTI FACT WORLD I AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
WE'VE NEVER SAID THIS IS THE
SOLUTION.
WE'VE SAID IT'S PART OF A BROAD
PUBLIC HEALTH ALLIANCE TO
EDUCATE TO PROTECT.
IN TO MOVE HELP FOR NOR
COMMUNITIES.
SO I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
AND TO BRING THIS BACK NEXT YEAR
WITH THE HOPE THAT THERE MIGHT
BE THE VOTES FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS IN WITH THAT I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
COURTESY IN ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MONEY
.
CENTER RUBIO PLEASE COME
FOR YES HAS DRAWN.
AS YOU'RE TERM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TâM PROUD TO PRESENT
SB [inaudible]
SIX FIFTY SECOND.
THE MOTION IS SECOND.
JUST REAL QUICKLY UP SB SIX
FIFTY WILL CREATE A COUNTER
MEDICATION ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IDENTIFYING
HOW TO BEST.
ASSIST CANCER PATIENTS ACCOUNT
FOR MEDICATION I'LL JUST LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS -- WE HAVE
CURRENTLY TWENTY ONE STATES THAT
ALREADY HAVE A CHANCE FOR A
MEDICATION PROGRAM.
AND FOURTEEN OF THOSE
SPECIFICALLY HAVE CANCER.
MEDICATION PROGRAMS TO HELP
ASSIST WITH LOW INCOME FAMILIES
LOW INCOME PATIENTS THAT CAN'T
AFFORD SUCH AN EXPENSIVE --
MEDICATION AND SO TO SAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GOT VOTE
BUT WE HAVE -- SOME OF THE FOLKS
HERE THAT WOULD ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THE SET SHORT PRISON THE
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ONCOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
AUTOMOBILE SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
NETWORK ALSO A CO SPONSOR US FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
Q..
THE BROTHERS AND SUPPORT.
MANY HERE WITH CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BEFORE YOU GOT OPPOSITION HAVE
YOU.
WILLING TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
CENTER REVIEW I'M SORRY YES
ABSOLUTELY AND THAT IS TO BE
SPECIFIC ON THE AMENDMENT SAYS
ON PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS YES ALL
EXCEPT THOSE MOMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEE KNOWN A RING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I'LL MAKE A QUICK COMMENT PLEASE --
THE HAVING DEALT WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT HAD CANCER AND HAVE
SINCE PASSED.
THERE WAS ALWAYS MEDICATION THAT
MY FATHER WOULD CRY ABOUT IS
LIKE I WISH SOMEONE ELSE COULD
USE THIS IT DIDN'T WORK FOR ME.
AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR ITS OF I
THINK THERE'S MANY OF US IN THE
SAME SHOES I'M AT THAT WERE
ALWAYS WONDERING WHAT YOU CAN DO
WITH IT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING.
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO -- ONE THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
BILL.
THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
NOTE THE JUST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN
CATCH UP TO THE FOURTEEN STATES
THAT ALREADY HAVE THE CANCER
PROGRAM IN THE TWENTY ONE STATES
THAT ALREADY HAVE.
JUST GENERAL MEDICATION A
TRANSFER PROGRAMS TO WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL THINKING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THE
MOTION WAS MADE BY -- MISTER
FLORA SECOND BY AGNES CURRY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IN MATHEMATICS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
HI WHAT I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA I'D BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO I FLORA FLOOR I LIVE
ALONE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I THIS
AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIZE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CLOSER. TWELVE VOTES HAS MORE
THAN ENOUGH TO GET OUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS DOWN TO
HAVE A SENATOR.
OKAY SO WE GO BACK -- TO BACK TO
TOP HERE -- AC ARE ONE OH FIVE A
MISTER -- TO WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION.
THE MOTION BY MISSILE LE MONA
SECOND BY MISTER BONTA -- THAT
IT IS MOTION IS TO PASS -- TWO
OF THE THIRTY ADOPTED A TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE NICE.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA NOT
BOATING Là MON.
LIMON I AM MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
NECESSARY AND I RAMOS ROSS I
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WATER.
NINE OKAY SO WE WILL GO ON TO
THE CONSECUTIVE CLUES ITEMS
NUMBER ONE TWO FIVE SEVEN NINE
THAT HAS PASSED BUT WILL OPEN
THE ROLE AND A CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SAW WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO BACK TO THE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
LIMON.
LOW ON IRON NECESSARY IN.
THIS AREA AND I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. FOURTEEN ZERO AT
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
FIFTY ONE FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
NIELSEN PLEASE -- OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
[inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMóN AYE SANTIAGO.
SB ONE FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
NELSON.
WHATEVER I WALDRON.
HI FOURTEEN ZERO AS FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN I BELIEVE EVERYONE.
WE DID NOT TAKE A VOTE SO WE'RE
DOING THAT AND THEN -- SB FIVE
NINETY ITEM NUMBER TEN BY
SENATOR STONE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
LOW MOAN.
LEVINE I YES.
I GUESS I AND WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE [inaudible]
YES.
NOT VOTING TO AYE BIGELOW NOT
VOTING NO I THIRTEEN THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
GONE THROUGH EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
OKAY -- OFFICE BURKE
YOU'RE JUST [inaudible]
COME.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH EVERYTHING
YEAH SO.
SO -- THE CONSENT CALENDAR BUT
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- ITEMS NUMBER
ONE TWO FIVE SEVEN AND EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE.
AND THEN -- ITEM ITEM NUMBER --
THREE IS HERE ONE OH FIVE PLEASE
OF THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE HI BURKE AYE
MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP TEN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BURKE I HI.
AT THE RIVER SIX SP ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WORK AYE
BURKE AYE. FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT WE DID NOT VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER TEN SB FIVE
NINETY PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SIR.
BURKE AYE. FOURTEEN ZERO AS
FOURTEEN ZERO AND FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB SIX FIFTY
PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANKS.
BURKE.
PARKER HI.
BECAUSE THIRTEEN ZERO WITH THAT
WE WILL CLOSE THE HEARING FOR
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU